welcome back to the machine learning
street talk youtube channel and podcast
today is a special community christmas
episode
use the table of contents to skip around
we're going to start off by having a
chat with
lightspeed yannick culture have a bit of
a catch up
we are going to do a little news section
where we talk about a few papers that
are interesting us at the moment
reader mail we have a few of you have
sent us in some messages
so we'll respond to those and also we
have a conversation with
a couple of the community members one
about
type theory and the other one about
inductive priors in
language models and gbt3 i am state of
the art do you
have the slightest idea how little that
narrows it down
i was wondering how much does
improvement over state-of-the-art mean
like really it means one paper
but like percent would it's it's if you
have if you
write the magic letters s-o-t-a
with the first and the last capitalized
the reviewers magically will
lift from their chairs and up to the sky
where they'll be treated to a massage
come back down
their hand will be guided to the accept
button guided
guided guided guided to the accept
button
merry christmas jingle bells jingle
bells jingle oh
yeah basically it's been a year of
machine learning street talk
and we're incredibly grateful to all of
you so many of you have left amazing
comments in the comments section every
single week it wouldn't be possible to
do this without you
but we recently passed 5k subscribers
and we're hurtling towards 10k
so yeah honestly thank you so much for
supporting us it's an absolute honour
and that's just the youtube subscribers
right there are many
more listening to this as a podcast
because
i mean as as good looking as we
are our faces talking probably aren't
the most exciting view so to all the
podcast listeners we
are actively trying to get more and more
into
making our content hearer friendly
rather than only viewer friendly but
remind us if we
you know if we fail every now and then
now um this week is a notional community
edition now some of you might not
realize but
yannick has a discord community and we
kind of share the discord community so
you know
i call it my home as well all of the
machine learning street talk folks are
in there
and we have about 2 000 people in there
it's a really vibrant community
i don't even know how this happened
there's this kind of weird
self-organizing behavior that happens
where
we've now got loads of community leaders
and they're running weekly
seminars about things and there's lots
of interesting conversations going on
so i guess the first thing is join the
community if you haven't already
it's also a great way to get more
interaction with us
let's look at a few papers that we
wanted to discuss
so this paper is quite an interesting
one it's just fairly fresh from deep
mind
object-based attention for space show
temporal reasoning
outperforming neurosymbolic models with
flexible distributed architectures
so there's been a big song and dance
lately about how
um the future is hybrid and how we need
to have neurosymbolic models
and then deepmind comes along and pretty
much seems to prove the opposite
or do they so in that abstract this is
by
ding etau neural networks have achieved
success in a wide array of perceptual
tasks
but it's often stated that they are
incapable of solving tasks
that require higher level reasoning two
new task domains
cleverer and cater have recently been
developed to focus on reasoning
as opposed to perception in the context
of spatial temporal interactions between
objects
initial experiments on these domains
found that neurosymbolic approaches
which couple a logic engine and language
parser
with a neural perceptual front end
substantially
outperform fully learned distributed
networks a finding that was taken to
support the above
thesis here they show the contrary
that a fully learned neural network with
the right inductive biases can perform
substantially better than all of the
previous neurosymbolic models on both of
these tasks
particularly on questions that most
emphasize reasoning over perception
their model makes critical use of both
self-attention and
learned soft object-centric
representations as well as bert style
semi-supervised predictive losses
these flexible biases allow their model
to surpass the previous neurosymbolic
state of the art
using less than 60 of the available
labeled data
so they think that these results refute
the neurosymbolic thesis laid out by
previous work
involving these data sets and they
provide evidence that neural networks
can indeed
learn to reason effectively about the
causal dynamic nature
or structure of physical events very
interesting
so i haven't read this paper in great
detail but this is basically their
architecture
so first of all what is the cleverer
data set well if you have a look at it
it's a diagnostic data set for
compositional language
and elementary visual reasoning so it's
a data set which has been
programmatically generated and this is
an example of an image
and you can ask questions so are there
an equal number of large things and
metal spheres
what size is the cylinder that is left
of the brown metal thing
uh that is left of the big sphere so
there are 70 000 images
and point seven million questions in
condition a
there's a validation set with about
fifteen thousand images and a hundred
fifty thousand questions
and a validation set of fifteen thousand
images and a hundred and fifty thousand
questions
on condition b okay interesting
okay so this is the overall architecture
um as you can see
we need to have representations for both
the question which is text and also the
um the vision information so they use
something called monet
for the vision and this segments each
frame into object representation so it
says it first uses a recurrent attention
network to obtain
a set of n object attention masks
where n is a fixed parameter and each
attention mask represents the
probability
that any given pixel belongs to the
mask's object
the pixels assigned to the mask are then
encoded into latent variables
okay so some kind of representation
algorithm for the vision space
they also do a kind of presumably a bert
style embedding
mechanism for the question and then they
link it together into a transformer and
positional encoding network
which has a self-supervised learning
phase and also a fine-tuning or
supervised learning phase as well now
what's really interesting is that why
would this work
right because we spoke to gary marcus
recently and he made it quite clear that
gbg3 was just a parlor trick it's just
learning patterns
yeah you might remember this paper i
think yannick did a video on this and
we've had guillaume lamppo
on the podcast and at the time people
thought well this is incredible they're
taking complex mathematical formulas
they're
converting it into a tree structure and
then they're using deep learning
to kind of predict the answers surely
that's only possible if you do reasoning
but the incredible thing about nature
is that there are always shortcuts
patterns always exist
and clearly we know how to do reasoning
or we know the rules
but it's possible for these deep
learning models to take shortcuts
and maybe that's what's happening here
in in this paper from deepmind
is it actually doing reasoning or do
shortcuts exist which we don't
completely understand
oh yeah so they are using you know
there's that clever data set
which has reasoning about objects and
their positions
and they've used a transformer
architecture
and they now outperform these
neurosymbolic models
that was certainly unexpected i've
wondered about this and there's some
crucial experiments missing there
you have these math problems and you
know
that the way like you can construct math
problems such that you know
the way to solve this thing needs to
somehow involve
this intermediate quantity so what you
could try to do is you could try to
recover that intermediate quantity
from the hidden states of the neural
networks if
it doesn't go via that intermediate
quantity you can be reasonably sure it
only does this sort of
interpolation trick so you know i i
think there's still
the jury's still out but my bet is also
that it's just
it's just kind of a yeah an
interpolation trickery
not trick it's cool but still well this
trickery thing is quite a recurring
theme
it all comes down to this philosophical
discussion of what does it mean
to understand you said yourself when you
deal with students
it's so easy to memorize things and as
an observer
you can't tell the difference yes yeah
there is this notion of understanding
like what does it mean to understand
and there is the other notion of do we
need this understanding like given that
understanding might be something
we could define that a.i
doesn't yet have do we need it to reach
agi
and there are people you know that that
argue something like ai doesn't
understand anything yet therefore it
can't
sort of evolve into agi but
i'm not so sure i'm not so sure
understanding is a real thing
and i also i'm not so sure if it is a
real thing
that it's necessary to build something
you would call agi
yeah it's quite interesting because i'm
trying to remember where where does this
come from
because understanding is something that
the go-fi people talk about all the time
so waleed sabha
made the argument that natural language
understanding is not the same thing as
processing
and in their conception it's all about
abstraction
so understanding is about having some
abstract model of the world and
having some explicit knowledge and being
able to reason over it
of course i mean of course it makes
total sense to make that argument right
it makes total because you
as a human you look at yourself and you
think
well am i really just doing forward prop
of some pattern to some pattern
probably not i do like i have some
internal voice in my head that speaks to
me and if i get you know if i encounter
a heart problem
i kind of sit down and i'm like
so clearly there is more going on in our
heads
than or seemingly more
going on than simple forward prop
through a neural network
right so it it does make total sense to
make the argument
that you know we do something like
understanding
the machines don't yet however
as i as i said i'm not sure
that this understanding thing is
actually something very different
from what the neural networks are doing
and i'm not sure that we need
this different thing if it exists to
build agi
and there there is the the jury's still
out so my argument
that i'm going to make that i don't
necessarily fully agree with
but that i could see as a possibility is
that what we lack so far is maybe just
multi modality
and what i mean by that is no wally taba
criticizes
something like gpt3 by saying law it
doesn't know
the elephant doesn't fit in the box
right it's
you know look at it he doesn't even know
that right
but of course it all it sees is text
right
from text how how it's supposed to but
we as humans we are
incredibly multi-modal we have we have
touch
we have gravity we have movement right
all of these are
sensory sensors that that we
input into our brain and our brain is
incredibly good at connecting these
different modalities
to each other and we underst understand
right what it means to for the elephant
to not fit into a small box because
we as a kid maybe have had the
experience of squeezing ourselves into
like
a cardboard box we have had the
experience of trying to
you know pack some luggage with too many
clothes and just
you know squeezing that thing in there
we
and if if you say i understand what it
means to fit into a box
i'm like you can make a strong case
that all that means is that you've had
these multimodal experience of
these things happening coupled with the
language input
well doesn't fit into it right and
and so so i'm not sure that
understanding
cannot arise from simply extending what
we have right now
to multi modality it's almost as if
you're making the argument that we have
a heterogeneous
brain so we have specialization
units in our brain for doing different
modalities and being able to abstract a
concept such that
it can be represented in all of these
different modalities and we can do some
kind of
message passing between those parts of
the brain
that's what understanding is to you
i'm not saying that's what it is what
i'm saying
but you you hit the correct point i'm
saying that
i am not convinced
that what these people call
understanding you know that necessary
component that machines don't yet have
cannot simply arise from scaling
what we have right now two different
modalities right
and yeah so it's it's very much along
the line of what like connor lee
would say and and he makes a good point
namely
that if these people claim there is
something like understanding
show show it to me show me where in the
brain right
is there something that you know
clearly does something
like this reasoning like symbolic where
in the brain is the structure that
doesn't
do this sort of forward propagation of
signal
because you can't find you can find very
complex neurons right with
you know you know lateral suppression
and whatnot and
extremely complex from but they're all
just signal processing
so so i'm not representing conor
accurately right here but he
he has this this point where he says
these people complain
that we need this sort of understanding
reasoning whatever but
never do they tell you where in the
brain that is
never do they actually define clearly
you know what's what's happening there
yeah i just don't like this multi-modal
argument because i think it's possible
to understand just in the
language domain i know you know conor
and you might not agree with that but
there is a subjective experience of what
is it like to understand
and it's surprisingly unambiguous when
you understand something
it means that you can make inferences
and deductions and you can
communicate it to someone else yes
though again under for example
understanding that you know an elephant
doesn't fit into
a suitcase is
something that might like that thing
might arise from multimodality
and i'm not sure there is a case of
understanding that doesn't arise from
multimodality
maybe you can make the point about
math like very abstract math but
i'm not so sure because that's that's
super
that's like very out there right from
all the things that humans
understand going into oh i'm gonna
prove i don't know girls in completeness
theorem
that is that is out there but on the
elephant thing i think you're making the
argument that if you
had access to multi-modal perception
you would just see lots of examples of
elephants being much bigger than boxes
and
of course they wouldn't fit in a box but
walid sabha would say that
just with very basic transitive
reasoning you would also be able to
deduce that an elephant wouldn't fit in
a box of course but
maybe that is because you've had
a rich experience of what it means to
not fit into something
you've had a rich experience of this
transitive property of
fitting right like you have had the
experience of packing something into a
box and then packing that box into a
bigger box
you have done it you have touched it you
have physically moved the object
and seen it with your eyes and felt you
know your hands going in there and so on
you
physically experience this transitive
property
of of fitting whereas a language model
has never had that interesting so
taking that subject a little bit further
we are talking with this
gentleman professor mark bishop in
february
and he's got a paper out called
artificial intelligence is stupid and
causal reasoning won't fix it now
the reason why i think you folks should
go and read this paper is
he really covers the entire scene of ai
and deep learning and also the the
causal reasoning stuff so the kind of
things that judea pearl and gary marcus
talks about
and so he starts talking about neural
computing and some of the limitations of
deep learning and
learning embeddings and so on and
variational autoencoders
and then we get down to causal reasoning
and what it means to understand
one of the interesting things is that he
invokes this chinese room which is
from john cell he came up with this
thought experiment called the chinese
room
where imagine you were an english person
and you're inside this room
and you had these people passing you
little bits of paper with chinese
written on
you don't understand chinese but someone
also gives you the rules
so you have all of the rules written
down and you know how to answer
questions in
chinese because you know which symbols
to manipulate and so on and you
you give the answers out and people
outside of that room think that you've
understood
right but you haven't understood it's
correct
people would say that once they knew of
the room
and so on like people would say you've
understood and then you'd say like look
it's all a trick it's
it's a room and i'm just doing this
right yeah but
but again that is that is very
like you're not a chinese room as a
human
clearly you don't simply do
rules into rules like you have some sort
of abstraction and reasoning capability
but again given for example transformers
they don't remember every single
training data point right
they do extract patterns from those data
points
and they do sort of use those patterns
and use them transitively so they use
the rules of grammar to stitch together
sentences and so on
i i just i don't see again
i don't necessarily i'm not arguing for
this i just say
there is a case to be made that
that will ultimately result in something
you you call understanding
and well okay let's say i talk to you
right and i would say you understand
things but then
some neurosurgeon comes in and says like
look it's all a twig there is this
structure in the brain and he's just
recalling the memory from here
and he's just you know using this neuron
and this neuron does this and
he's not really understanding he's just
saying the things that the brain
you know outputs and you know
can i make the same argument well yeah
you can the question is do we even need
to have understanding because
one of the things i want to get away
from a little bit is very quickly these
discussions get into philosophy of mind
and they get into
the esoterics of consciousness and so on
and i think you're making quite an
interesting point which is that well
it doesn't really matter for all intents
and purposes if it
appears to understand then who cares if
it's an illusion because we're getting
into this
this concept of as a human what does it
mean to understand and is there a gap
this is what mark talks about in his
paper so he says at the end that
he thinks that even these causal
reasoning approaches
they go one step further i mean
ultimately
what what he's what he concludes with
it he builds up this case that
understanding is needed
and there is this kind of
cohort of people coming from the the
causality
angle saying we have the answer right
causality is the answer if you if you
program causality
into your ml systems that will that will
solve that problem and it is
true that using causality you can
solve a whole bunch of problems that you
couldn't solve before
but this this paper is basically saying
well yes you've made one step but you
still not
you ha still haven't solved the problem
the understanding question is still here
you've done nothing to address that yeah
so he says no matter how sophisticated
the computation is
how fast the cpu is or how great the
storage of the computing machine
is there remains an unbridgeable gap
which is the so-called humanity gap
between the engineered problem-solving
ability of a machine
and the general problem solving ability
of man and this is basically what john
searle said
he said that this kind of computationism
ideology
will never really get you to understand
it although
there have been a lot of um criticism to
that recently so you can take a level of
abstraction up and you can say well
maybe the entire system maybe the
building and the inputs and the outputs
and
the person inside the building maybe
that system constitutes some level of
understanding
yeah well this this so i have two points
i think that the one point i've already
made which is that
it is it is not even even if humans do
something like
understanding it doesn't mean that
that's a necessary component of agi
it does it is a necessary component if
we want to build
a artificial human it is not a necessary
component if we want to build an
artificially generally intelligent
machine these are two different things
and i think it's a good point to make
right saying like look humans do this
thing
let's take that for granted because even
though i doubt
it like that humans do this distinctly
but let's say human do this thing
machine doesn't do this thing therefore
machine
cannot be and here's the distinction
that what they say
what they want or what they need to say
is machine cannot be like human
okay but machine cannot be
artificially generally intelligent only
if you define
agi in terms of you know acts exactly as
it acts not only as a human does
but also in a way like achieves its
conclusions in a way as the human does
there's nothing that says agi can't use
a different method to
to solve its problems and or needs this
understanding
whatever it is and the second thing is
that this is exactly like
the uh creationism
design crowd you know every time
they go like well this system here
is irreducibly complex if you
you know that there is you know
evolution can only explain so much there
will always
be a gap to for that evolution
cannot explain and it it it reminds me
too much of you know
this this thing and as you said you
bring up a good point like if a human
understands something certainly a
building with a human in it
understands the same thing and
so so is is is the building now
understanding like it seems to be a bit
too human-centric
and a bit a bit
more like like what someone wants to
arrive at a conclusion someone wants to
arrive at
then a conclusion that is that is well
reasoned
if you have any questions for professor
mark bishop let us know
because he will be on the podcast in
february
okay oh god this ruined my rep
you didn't know that his first action
will be to just
pair my mute me
[Laughter]
not at all no no he's he's a very nice
chap
so the next thing is we wanted to talk
about this paper by
professor pedro domingos pedro
is reasonably well known lately if
you're on twitter
for reasons which need not detain us
but the paper is called every model
learned by gradient descent
is approximately a kernel machine so
he says in the abstract that deep
learning's success is often attributed
to its ability to automatically discover
new representations
of the data rather than relying on
handcrafted features
and deep learning is sold as
representation learning
you can essentially learn a really
generalizable
representation of your data and that
will
work on previously unseen data and if
they are
equivalent to kernel machines we all
know we spoke about this on our kernel
methods episode a colonel is just an
inner product of your training data
right which means
all you're doing is memorizing your
training data
i the the ghost of alex
will come visit you tonight and scream
at you
for doing such a terrible job i i can't
do a better job at it
just saying yeah i think i think there
are a couple of ingredients right here
so the claim he makes is that
you know in a kernel machine what you do
essentially is
you you simply a kernel machine always
explicitly has
the training data set as part of the
algorithm
so in a kernel machine what
what you would do is you would keep the
training data set around at least
a part of the training data set namely
the the support vectors
right but these are actual data points
that you keep around
for the algorithm to work right the
algorithm relies on you remembering
these training
data points and then the kernel sort of
tells you how to measure
the distance of any new point to these
training data points
that's that's what the kernel tells you
and
the the paper here makes the claim that
a deep learning
is essentially the same thing if the
deep learning is learned with gradient
descent so gradient descent
is a necessary component here so that
the claim
from what i can gather and i have not
had a deep look at this paper
yet so i don't want to say too much
though
i can i can probably try to trash it
a bit no this is a joke that's what a
conference reviewer would do
i've read a bit of the abstract i don't
like it
so you would say that like
[Laughter]
i'm pretty sure most a lot of conference
reviewers get about that far
into a paper but so so the the argument
here is that
even though we think we're learning
these deep neural networks ultimately
ultimately what they just do is they
learn
a superposition of the training data
as a kernel machine does like they kind
of keep
important training data points around
and then
by virtue of how the neural network is
structured as a neural
network right and the specific
architecture it has that sort of
constitutes the kernel function
that sort of tells you how to to measure
distances
between these data points but you don't
you just you don't keep them around
explicitly but you do
keep them around sort of in the in the
weights
and and gradient descent is the
necessary ingredient
here to make that claim work which
i i can believe that as i said i haven't
read the paper
so what i'm going to guess is that there
is an
argument a mathematical argument that
shows this equivalence
but i would what i would also guess is
that
you can probably extend that to a lot
more
than deep neural networks you can you
can go
say i don't know random forests or
kernel machines if they're learned with
or are they learned of gradients
i don't know but you you could probably
make the same argument or the same type
of argument
for a lot of architectures and
ultimately
uh sort of show that everything is
equivalent to everything else
because ultimately they do learn a
decision function from training data so
at some point the training data needs to
come into the process right
and whether or not they're remembered
explicitly or implicitly once you
wash that away you might be able to make
anything into anything okay well
though there might be a much deeper
connection here than what i'm saying
right now
i'm just i'm sort of sort of trying to
to take a job at it
okay well if you folks are interested in
yannick doing a deep dive on pedro's
paper
or indeed having pedro on the podcast
then let us know in the comments
but one interesting thing that did come
up is
svms and kernel methods that they're
known as non-parametric
models and a bit of an intuition there
is
the parametric bit means in deep
learning you have all of these weights
that you learn they're
they're the parameters and in these
kernel methods in these non-parametric
models
the data basically is the model so
that's the reason for the
you know the two different descriptions
there so the next one is our friend
yoshi benzio we did a really interesting
street talk on his iclr talk talking all
about the consciousness prior
he has this idea that you can create a
kind of
you know set of inductive priors for
deep learning that will learn a sparse
factor graph of how things are related
to each other
and you could also learn causal
relationships between those semantic
objects and he thinks that that is the
future of ai so it's quite interesting
we were saying this earlier that
yoshi benzio is now a fully signed up
member of the gophi initiative
i wouldn't i wouldn't go quite quite as
far
to claim that but but banjo has been
always much like much like hinton i
believe
always coming from the very practical
side
from a neuroscientific side from sort of
a cognitive science
side and just has always been trying to
actually build
these sort of priors that humans
naturally have or that brains naturally
have
into these models i mean think about
capsule networks
by by hint and these are this is hinton
sort of trying to think about what goes
on in
in the brain in and and make
an explicit model based on that that
mixes the sort of
you know neural things that we have with
with these
these these priors and the capsule
networks i think is an awesome
example of that and banjo has been
doing one form of another one form or
another
of this for a long time
awesome okay so that paper is called
inducted biases for deep learning of
high level cognition it was out on the
7th of december
so check that out who is anna rogers
let's click on this so she is a
postdoctoral associate at the university
of copenhagen she's interested in
natural language processing and working
on interpretability and and so on so
that's super interesting
so she had a paper out on the gradient
talking about a survey which she's just
written
of the bertology literature cool i think
i think i had that previous paper
as a video on my channel the when bert
plays the lottery
all tickets are winning oh yes so what
was your take on that
well the first lesson never title a
video like this
because a whole lot of people show up
trying to win the lottery and
being terribly disappointed when once
they realize it's not about winning the
lottery
i i don't i honestly don't fully
remember what exactly the claim of the
paper was
so but it did investigate
i believe it investigated fine-tuning
of bert and sort of pruning
the different heads and
i believe what it found was sort of that
it could prune in a lot of ways and
still fine-tune
too good performance and that that's
kind of where the title
all tickets are winning comes from right
interesting but there are some sections
here talking about how stable are the
good sub-networks found across
random initializations and across
different tasks so
things like some of the different glue
tasks
and i remember all of these graphics i i
do not remember the conclusions
because one interesting thing was
there's a graph here
showing um different types of patterns
on the
self-attention networks self-attention
pattern types yeah it says
so cavaliera 2019
revealing the dark secrets of bert
okay so this is quite interesting so
there are roughly four types of patterns
so um for those of you who watch simon
cormlef he used quite an interesting
um way of looking at the evolution of
representations in neural networks and
you'll
recognize that characteristic block
pattern from that
so these folks looked at different types
of self attention patterns
and there are vertical patterns and
diagonal patterns and vertical and
diagonal block patterns and
heterogeneous patterns and rogers said
here that the heterogeneous pattern if
you're actually learning anything about
language
you would kind of wanted to be
heterogeneous and what they did was they
trained a cnn classifier on this
self-attention matrix to
you know go ahead and and see what kind
of
patterns of activation patterns there
are on different networks trained for
different downstream tasks and then
they've done a kind of
visualization here showing what the kind
of proportion of those different
activation patterns are
and presumably you want there to be more
heterogeneous because that means it's
actually doing something interesting
i'm not so sure like
why like there is if there is an
you know a central piece of
like a word that's very important like
you need to
entity link and it seems okay
that all the attention is on this token
that is the entity
like you know i'm i'm not
not convinced that heterogeneous doesn't
just mean you have no clue what you're
doing
maybe
i could be wrong that's the problem with
birthology isn't it we just don't know
but yeah so her conclusion was that the
lottery ticket hypothesis holds when
using magnitude pruning on bert
good sub-networks can be retrained to
reach full model performance
structured pruning tells a different
story so we find that pruning most of
the sub-networks of burt
using this method results in similar
performance between good random and bad
sub networks so the experiments suggest
that bert's high performance does not
come from specific linguistic knowledge
uniquely encoded
in the pre-trained weights of specific
birch components
otherwise the good sub networks would
have been stable across random seeds
anyway it was a really interesting
article so definitely go check that out
not too much news in the ml world the
other thing we're going to talk about is
gary marcus shared a really interesting
conversation with loads of luminaries
over in montreal at the the institute
that they have over there
and gary kind of started off by saying
something quite interesting ai systems
that understand the variables they
manipulate
including language perception and action
we should try to understand what
understanding itself means
um we want systems that can capture
causality capture how the world works
understand abstract actions reason and
plan explain what happened and
generalize out of distribution this is
just
stunning convergence i believe and uh
one more example jurgen
huber and uh some collaborators just had
a paper uh
earlier this month um arguing for a
compositional approach to ai in terms of
symbol-like
representations and said that they said
that was fundamental
um in realizing human level
generalization so
you know we spent the last eight years
arguing about whether we need these
things and i think we now all agree or
almost
all agree he really thinks that there's
been a convergence because gary marcus
was always the pariah
he was the troll that everyone really
hated because he was saying
you know you're all wrong it's all
reasoning and this that the other and
actually there seems to be a real
convergence now which gary points out so
even uh
uber in his paper which was
the binding problem in artificial neural
networks even he was talking about the
need for causal reasoning and
the sub-symbolic processing and so on
and of course spoken about this paper
from
bengio saying the same thing so it's got
to the point now where that's not really
a controversial thing to say anymore
you won't get cancelled for it you won't
get cancelled for it
so gary marcus has been allowed back
into the
the fold his opinions are no longer you
know the overton window is now kind of
you know it's including gary marcus
you're you're allowed yeah you're
allowed to be a reasonist
in today's ai community no but i i mean
these these are valid
criticisms and they you know there have
always been
i i think the outliers have more been
the neural networkers i guess until
recently
but there there's always this criticism
of your neural network can't do
understanding
it doesn't explicitly reason over
symbols
and so on so and the answer to that is
yes probably it doesn't though i'm not
sure
what an attention mechanism does
like could very well reason over symbols
you don't know sorry the answer to that
is their thing doesn't understand either
yeah well well you can't like you can't
like the criticism is valid even if you
can say you too
you more you more
yeah though yes though the
yeah the back argument is more like yeah
then you know taste your own medicine
and tell me where
you know where in the brain that happens
and you know where where there is this
entirely distinct
part because that i
i think that can't be pointed out so far
and and as i said all of before
i'm not i'm not so sure even though the
criticism is
sounds valid i'm not so sure it's
necessary
okay so there was a really interesting
bit by rich sutton so i've not really
heard him speak much before so it's
quite an interesting experience for me
to hear him speak
david maher the neuroscientist and
vision researcher
david mario died in 1980 at the age of
35.
what he's most known for is the
three-level
hypothesis which is um
that any information plastic system must
be understood at three levels in the
computational theory level about the
problem
and breaking down into algorithms and
hardware implementation
the computational theory level is what i
want you to really
focus on so what is the goal of the
computation that's what we look at in
computational theory
what are the purposes why is it
appropriate to to compute certain things
rather than other things
whereas um next level down the middle
level is
how would that be done which
representations in which algorithms
would be used
and finally the lower level is again how
but how physically could it be done
so david maher liked to emphasize the
computational theory level
he thought it was the most important and
at the same time the most neglected
and i think it's still true in
neuroscience that
we are missing sort of a high level
understanding
of the goal and the purposes of the
overall
uh mind it's also true in artificial
intelligence but perhaps more
surprisingly in ai but there's really
very little computational theory
in in in mars sense in ai so for example
in ai textbooks they will often decline
to define the problem of intelligence
it's important always to understand the
problem before you approach the solution
and other ideas production rules bayes
updating some assumption gradient
descent dynamic system theory all these
are housed
they're not what's they don't
characterize the overall problem
so then that brings me to my thesis that
reinforcement learning is the first
computational theory of intelligence
reinforced learning is explicit about
the goal
about the what's and the whys so
according to reinforcement the goal
is to maximize an arbitrary reward
signal to this end
the agent has to compute a policy a
value function a generative model
and each of these contributes in a clear
way to maximizing reward and each is a
clear
what the value function for example is a
function from states
to a prediction of the future award and
he cited that there are
three levels at which information uh
processing can be understood
the top level is computational theory
the middle level is the representation
and the algorithm and the third level is
hardware implementation
so the the nub of what he is saying is
that
almost all of the the folks at the
moment whether it's you know causal
people
symbolic people neural networkers they
are all at that middle tier
and he thinks that he's sitting at the
top of the tree because
as a reinforcement learning person he
has this
unifying computational paradigm and
a big part of this is the the what's
not the house so he thinks at his level
it comes back to our conversation that
we had on chile's measure of
intelligence right we
we spoke about hutter's universal
conception of intelligence
and that was basically it's what
deepmind teach to kids at
ucl they teach hata's conception which
is that
intelligence is basically an agent
performing
actions in us in a variety of
environments
well yes though i don't agree with these
i mean these levels of it can
be understood yes of course like any
computation can be understood you can
look at the hardware level you can look
at and so on
but i don't i don't agree if this is in
fact what
what he says here i don't agree that rl
has any
any claim to fame like it's it's the
most general yes but it also means that
i can
i can frame any problem as an rl problem
i can frame a supervised learning
problem
as a reinforcement learning problem and
then presumably i'm on that same level
right like to understand
why a computation is useful okay why
why is the supervised learning useful
because you
can predict the labels right why do you
do this because i want to predict the
label
you know that that you can always frame
this
as as rl and just because rl is the most
general
framework doesn't i don't think it's
any more powerful it's like the higher
level programming languages aren't
more powerful than the lower level
programming languages
just because you you have different
levels of abstraction
i know it because it shouldn't come as
any surprise to us that
because rich sutton is from deepmind
isn't he so clearly
he's going to advocate for a theory of
intelligence which makes
deep mind look good and i was really
shocked when i first read francois
shelley's measure of intelligence paper
because he basically said that
the most important thing is
generalization
the algorithms that have come from
deepmind whether it's alphago
or mu0 and so on they're really clever i
mean architecturally these folks are
amazing that they've come up with
a way of gluing together all of these
different ideas they've effectively
combined
searching and learning and they have
achieved things that
that are wonderful by throwing loads of
computation at it
they've achieved a high level of skill
but
it's not efficient the information
conversion ratio is very low
and there is zero generalization so
i'm not surprised that he's chosen this
particular measure of intelligence
yeah i mean you can always construct
something that
you're at the top especially if you're
deep mind
that's an easy task right yeah so this
is not
yeah as you say like deepmind does
awesome things
like more more awesome than i think than
we will
ever do you know yeah there's there's
some there's there's really awesome
talent
at deepmind and
yes the algorithms they come up with
ultimately they are
super duper narrow and i guess the
question is
how well could these algorithms be
ported uh to some other problem
and there the answer is you know
unfortunately also
not super easy like like i can't just
take alpha fold
and being a normal software engineer
maybe a bit of an ml engineer i couldn't
straightforwardly use that to solve
i don't know a traffic traffic jam
problem or something like this
even though that's it appears to be
fairly close
in sort of the problem domain even their
their most general algorithm
or some of their most general algorithms
like like deep q learning or maybe mu0
right which doesn't even need an
internal simulator
even those they rely on very very tight
constraints right you need to be in this
you need to be in this state where you
can simulate data
infinitely restart at will always have
the same actions available
the input is always in its nice shape
and so on
it's it so the the skill
needed to transfer the algorithm to
another problem
is considerable and even then it might
not be possible you might only
be able to you know transfer the idea of
the algorithm
so essentially what chole would argue
and
what i i argue here too is that the the
intelligent bit
is is in the engineers right having the
ideas of
let's combine learning with search in
some way
yeah but what's interesting there is how
much of that forms a universal model
of ai computation because it seems quite
general
even with alpha fold they're potentially
using max wellings
you know se3 transformer and yeah
there's some domain knowledge built into
the system there but it's still largely
a blank slate in the sense that it could
be applied to almost anything
you just need to be very very smart yeah
that's the point right you need to be
smart in the in the input like of course
reinforcement learning as a framework
applies to anything that's that's what i
was saying initially right
so rl as there's an agent there's a
world
there is a reward signal that i can
frame
almost any problem in that setting so
yes
it is like all the ultimate the ultimate
model of computation
however just because you can frame
anything
you know in wikipedia there's this game
where we always take the the first
[Music]
non-non-italic non-in bracket link
right and you always click that and from
like i think from every page you
ultimately get to philosophy
but it doesn't help when when you ask me
you know what's you know
where's uh or what's what's moscow
and i say philosophy like it doesn't
even though it
might be correct in some membership
graph it it's not
very helpful okay so
there was another really interesting uh
person interviewed so
i'm sure you've heard of daniel kahneman
thinking fast and slow
we've had so many conversations when we
talk about yoshi abengio
yeah so everyone talks about this
dichotomy of system one system two and
the go five people think that
their stuff is system two reinforcement
learning people think that planning is
system two
and daniel kahneman said that originally
when he when he came up with this
conception
he he kind of thought about it
differently i should talk about two
systems
i seem to be identified with the idea of
two systems system one and system two
although they're not my idea but i did
write a book
that described them and
as quite a few of you sure know
we talk about the contrast between one
system that works fast another that
works slow
the main difference between system one
and system two as i described them
was that system one is something that
happens to you
you are not active the thought that the
words come to you the ideas come to you
the emotions come to you they happen to
you
you do not do them and the essential
distinction that i was drawing
between the two systems was really that
one
something that happens to you and
something that you do
high level skills in my description of
of things
were absolutely in system one anything
that we can do automatically
anything that happens associatively is
in system one
operation the system one tend to be
parallel operations or system two tend
to be serial
and this idea of two systems may have
been
adopted uh more than it should have been
it seemed to be identified with the
distinction between symbolic and
non-symbolic
where system one is non-symbolic and
system two symbolic
one that does the reasoning uh and
there is i had a very similar view
myself when
you look at what machine learning does
it reminds you of that black box
that produces miraculously and quite
fast
produces very complicated responses or
responses in very complicated situations
so it's true that anything
any activity that we would describe as
non-symbolic
i think does belong to system one
that system one i think cannot be
described as a non-symbolic
for one thing uh it's
it's much too complicated and rich for
that it knows language for one thing
intuitive thoughts
are in language uh the most interesting
component
of system one the basic component as i
conceive of that notion
is that it holds a representation of the
world
and and the representation that actually
allows something that resembles the
simulation of the world
as i describe it we we live
with that representation of the world
and most of the time
we are in what i call the valley of the
normal there are events that we
positively expect
there are events that surprise us but
most of what happens to us
neither surprises us nor is it expected
what i'm going to do
to say next will not surprise you but
you didn't actually expect it
so there is that model that compares
that accepts many many
events as normal continuations of what
happens
but it rejects some and it distinguishes
what is surprising from what is normal
that's very difficult to describe in
terms of symbolic or non-symbolic
certainly what happens is a lot of
counter factual thinking
is in fact system one thinking because
surprise is something that happens
automatically
you're surprised when something that
happens
is not normal is not expected
and that forces common sense
and causality to be in system one and
not in system two
so i wanted just to
clarify the language a bit that it seems
to me that
uh the association of system two
specifically with symbolic
and system one with non-symbolic uh
i really enjoy hearing those two systems
mentioned in conversations about ai
but i'm not sure that they're always
used as precisely as they should be he
thought
that system one is something that
happens to you
system two is something that you do
that's
yeah that's quite a smart conception
though i think the
the crucial word in that sentence
interestingly enough is you like
what is you right like it's all it's
almost like he
he you know by defining you you
automatically define what system one and
system two it clearly he sees
the you like the and i don't know coming
you know
if if like the buddhists would go into
this ego
right the ego is an illusion thing and
so on and they
they they're all about you have this
notion of this you
but doesn't actually exist so i guess
kahneman here framing it like this
clearly sees the you
as sort of like sitting on top of your
unconscious
right of your subconscious right and the
system one is this
you know the subconscious it happens to
you means the computation
is somewhere else so the computation is
outside of you
in some maybe other part of your brain
right and then it happens to you meaning
that
you know it's at the end of the
computation the result is sent to you
to to the sort of conscious part of your
brain whereas
system two is what you do
it means that maybe it's going on inside
that whatever you is but it entirely
this entirely now hinges on the
definition of you
what is you and uh yeah
philosophy i know everything seems to go
there quite quickly as you say
the other thing that fascinated me is
reminded me a lot of the conversation
that we had with professor carl fristen
he says that most of the time that we
are in the valley of the normal
that there are events that we positively
expect
and there are events that surprise us
but most of what happens to us
neither surprises us nor is it expected
what he's going to say he said in the
next few minutes will not surprise you
but you didn't
actually expect it so in professor
fristen's
conception he has this wonderful idea
that we all have a generative model and
of course we do we we have the
simulation
like the matrix going on in our brains
and we're always running different
simulations and
even as as we talk with each other now
we have some idea of what's expected
and we're trying to minimize surprise
and fristen basically says that we have
a bayesian brain we're constantly trying
to
minimize surprise which is basically you
know
kind of predictive error between these
external sensory states and our internal
states
and we have this kind of entropy and
surprise that we are continuously
updating
so why don't we do that in machine
learning
yes so this this here if if i had to
name
a component that was still missing from
our
today's ai systems it would
not be a symbolic reasoning component
if i if i had to name one it would be
a an internal generative model
at this could be at an abstract level
like it doesn't need to be at
the base level of reality but like some
sort of
forward generative model that you have
internally
seems seems like something that we don't
yet do and i also don't see how it can
sort of arise i can see how something
like reasoning can
sort of arise from from the kind of
neural computation that we do
i i don't necessarily see how something
like
planning over a a internal generative
model can just
happen and maybe we need to build that
in that being said there have
have been a lot of rl systems that have
tried to have such an explicit system
with
more or less success mostly less success
it tends to be incredibly painful to you
know build that in
to somebody to back prop through it and
then what you do if it's not
super accurate yeah i think hari had
this this
this problem as well where you say okay
what what if i can't trust my model and
so on this
yeah and this this notion of surprises
is
something i would definitely agree with
and
it it reminds me of a a talk i heard by
jordan peterson who said something like
if if you're going in a car and you go
from a to b
like you don't even think
you're just you don't think i'm in a car
and there's an engine and blah blah blah
blah blah
you just think i'm going from a to b the
entire complexity
of the car and of the world around you
it just vanishes
because everything is happening
according
to what you expect and here he says
something interesting is is
that it's not that you expect every
single detail
right if if i drive somewhere and i
don't really know where i'm going but
i don't care right that like that house
that is by it might not match my
internal simulator
but it's irrelevant right because my
internal simulator it operates at
sort of the things that should be
relevant and the biggest category
for for your brain is the things that
are irrelevant
so if you're in the car going from a to
b almost everything is irrelevant
because your internal simulator tells
you
everything's going fine but then someone
bumps into you and
all of a sudden what the world is
doesn't match anymore with what your
simulator tells you
you should be experiencing like your
simulator tells you you should be just
going like this
but the world tells you like bang and
now all of a sudden
all of a sudden complexity arises and
your brain
and all of a sudden the car is now a car
because it's broken
right and in all of the complexity of
the car
gets into your mind and there wasn't
there before so
this this notion of surprise
and and you you thinking like your
system kicking in when something
surprises you and so on that
is something i very much agree with and
something we don't do
something like alphago plans every step
right like they can modulate the time a
bit i think and they have some
confidence measure but
still like mu zero it plans every every
step it just plans whatever 100
steps 100 times right but most of what
you do is you don't plan at all
until you reach something where
there's complexity then you plan a lot
and that
depends on that internal simulator you
have and
that's something i think we're still
missing does this imply that we
should have a bayesian system because if
you think about it the
really powerful thing with um bayesian
systems is that
you have kind of irregularly sample data
in the in the real world so
you can when you encounter entropy
when you actually need to do some
thinking then you can go and sample in
that space
and it seems to be a really efficient
way of working because you said yourself
i don't know how well this applies to
you know to current deep learning
methods but
at the moment you have to take a
trajectory through this policy
and why would you encounter anything
that surprised you in in
in that case well okay i'm i'm never
sure about this
this whole bayesian stuff because i'm
fairly convinced our brains aren't
aren't as basin as we would like to
think like i don't i don't keep the
entire distribution of things in my
brain at all times like i don't
i don't right i have like
the i've the the most likely thing and
maybe one other thing that i consider
right and and
you know when i do planning i do
explicit planning over these things i
don't
do planning over the distributions of
things and
i don't update my prior according to
bayes rule
i you know i do something much more dumb
so
i i don't think we nest it might be
that we get really good performance by
doing bayesian stuff
christoph koch also spoke at the event
so
the point i'm trying to make here is
that these massive resources
reveal brains made out of
amazing complexity none of which is
reflected in
any machine learning models on any
of the current models of ai
what what this uh reveals including the
the connectoms that we're now getting
both
uh the complete connectomes of cubic
millimeters of tissue both in the mouse
and
in the in the humans they reveal that
these brains are not only made out of
millions of billions of neurons and glia
cells
not just excitatory and inhibitory cells
but a a fantastic just a mind-blowing
variety of cell types
on the order of now we estimate a
thousand different cell types neuronal
cell types
that differ by the developmental origin
that differ by the genes they express
the layer in which their cell bodies is
located which is critical to understand
anything in cortex
the addresses they send the information
to they differ in the synaptic
architecture
in the the in their dendritic trees in
the
um in the electrophysiological functions
etc
so we have you know highly heterogeneous
individual components
roughly a thousand times that combine
both the functionality of computation
and memory so very different than our
current you know
vlsi hardware into these densely
interwoven networks
with fan in and fan out on the order of
ten thousand
all right so this really exceeds
anything that science has ever
has ever studied with these highly
heterogeneous components on the out of a
thousand with
with connectivity on the order of ten
thousand
that the brain is the most highly
organized piece of active matter in the
in the known universe and if i look at
the state-of-the-art
you know deep neural networks they're
really very impoverished and bind
a they're very impoverished so by and
large they have you know halfway
rectified or you know
gain control saturating units so two or
three different types compared to a
thousand different types that we see in
the brain
and so understanding brains and their
pathologies
uh it's a project probably that's gonna
take us a century or two
the dirty secret of my field is that we
don't like to talk about
we have a connector with a complete
wiring diagram of c
elegans since 1986 okay that's the third
of a century
there's still no general purpose
integrated model of
of of its final two neurons right and
here we're trying to understand the 16
billion neurons that make up the
and then and the human brain
brains primarily provide existence proof
that adaptive intelligence
is possible in physical hardware
i mean that's a general argument
especially coming from neuroscientists
that the brain
is so much more complex than
our neural networks even the individual
neuron
is so much more intriguing and complex
than simply forward prop like there is
effects like you know long-term
potentiation
and and i don't know you know dendrites
going over other dendrites and synapses
going over other synapses
you know stopping these synapses and and
crazy stuff going on in even in the
individual neuron level and often these
neuroscientists will say
something like you have no chance
you know you you just building this one
type of neuron this
not even neuron it's like this linear
algebra
thing it's just and that's valid
but again i would say if our goal was to
build a brain
we won't get there like we do but
you never know if the things that we
find in the brain
are because they are necessary for let's
say
intelligence or it's simply there
because of other reasons
namely for example maybe the brain needs
to be immensely energy efficient
so maybe nature wanted to build
a linear algebra machine a neural
network but it said well that's just
bloody and efficient so i'm going to
have to you know
use you know this i'm going to have to
make a bunch of cells you know a bunch
of cell
types to work around these efficiency
constraints that i have but actually
would be better just to build
the linear algebra machine and and it
could be
you know that that the evolutionary
process
you know also the goal was hey i want to
build
the the best system would be the linear
algebra machine but i can't build it
in an evolutionary fashion step by step
by step by step
right so what i'll what i'll do
is i need a system that i can build step
by step and that's
going to include these you know
thousands of cell types
so i guess the my whole argument would
be is
yes the brain is infinitely more complex
than our neural networks
and that would be a problem if our goal
was to build a human brain
but if our goal is to build something
that is intelligent
it might not be necessary to rebuild
this complexity like we might get there
using a different system yeah although
there's quite an interesting point that
ezrae made recently which is that it
it is quite a good way to go to think
about energy efficiency
because probably the human brain might
not be required for
intelligence but maybe it's no
coincidence that in nature
energy efficiency was deemed to be so
important
yeah well well that's that's mainly
because you know food is scarce
right and your brain needs to work when
you're
super duper hungry and like especially
then it needs to work
right if you're out of food you're out
of energy your brain still needs to
function so it's no wonder that there is
this energy efficient this hyper focus
on their
energy efficiency however
it's we we don't necessarily need that
right
we can like we can we can dig up oil and
burn it
like as much like almost as much as we
want we
you know it's um not not saying that's a
good thing but
our energy efficiency
is not nearly as much a problem for for
our artificial neural networks
as it is for the human brain but i guess
because we spoke to simon stringer as
well from oxford and he was saying that
there you know there's uh predictive
rating coding and there's
uh pulses and you know koch was
basically saying that
the existence proof of intelligence is
the human brain and you know just wait a
minute guys
have a look at what's going on in the
human brain it's incredibly
heterogeneous
it's incredibly complex it seems to
imply
that you guys are just barking up the
wrong tree because how can having
how with such a monolithic feed-forward
architecture do you seriously expect
to reproduce anything that resembles
intelligence it's a bit provocative but
i think that's his point
yeah i mean it's it's a good point but
that's
you know building building the car by
making the horse faster
like there's yes the only intelligent
thing we know
has these properties doesn't mean that
intelligence needs
needs these properties
another really interesting speaker at
that montreal event was
my favorite professor kenneth stanley um
he thinks that actually open-endedness
is one of the most important um
features for building something that
resembles what we call intelligence
now um we've actually got a special
edition with kenneth
coming up in the next couple of weeks so
rather than going to that now i think we
should
keep our powder dry and save it for
later we also had some reader mail right
yeah so this chap marcus carr got in
touch with us and he said uh
i'm the smart aleck who bought up
capsule networks a couple of weeks ago
in the comments yes indeed
as a cs grad student his focus right now
is on hierarchical attention
based networks and he's been deep in the
weeds on this stuff lately
so regarding capsule networks in the
latest version iterative routing has
been dropped in favor of a transformer
well that's really interesting because
there is a clear conceptual similarity
between
the transformer system and the routing
the authors induce sparsity with an
additional loss term and it seems to
work very well for them
hinton discussed it here and i'll share
the links in the description on the
video
the lead author blogged it somewhere
else which i'll link as well regarding
compositionality and priors apparently
there's a paper called recursive
cortical networks worth a look
they are extremely sample efficient and
have a hierarchical structure like that
of capsule networks
with two key differences one they are
bayesian probabilistic
graphical models not neural networks and
two they encode a different prior which
is the fact that objects are enclosed
shapes with surfaces and contours
interesting so
for his thesis he's building an rcn like
structure
again i'll share the link but with
transformers the key is to recast image
recognition as a sequence to sequence to
sequence problem
instead of translating between tokens
they translate between sets of learned
queries
and facebook's detr uses
learned queries too but for a different
purpose each set of queries constitutes
a layer
and the attention matrices between them
act as weights the difference is that
each neuron outputs a vector not a
scalar
and the weights are not fixed but depend
on the context
so in this formulation self-attention
serves as lateral connectivity
or competition within a layer while
cross-attention allows for dynamic
routing
between layers okay so markus said that
he doesn't plan to build this into any
prize because he thinks the architecture
is general enough
to be used in multiple domains for
example he's testing on both
mnist and the pen tree bank and with
this set up he says that you can also do
neat things with attention masks
like fine-tune unsupervised models for
classification
anyway he says he's a big fan of the
channel and also connor's channel henry
ai labs
shout out to connor and yannick's
channel too so
marcus thank you so much for sending
that and here is your reply from alex
rolltape so a couple of weeks ago on
machine learning street talk
we were discussing capsulenets the
jeffrey
hinton inspired reformulation of cnns
that you know kind of first came up
about 10 years ago
and started seeing practical
implementations in the last couple of
years
and in in response to this segment this
this guy by the name of marcus carr sent
him an email
and this was a really good email first
thing he does is he sets us straight
so people on the show chiefly myself
were laughing at the idea of you know
the
in the paper capital networks with em
routing they have this internal
optimization loop on every forward pass
of their network to handle their
attention mechanism
and i remember thinking at the time this
just looks like a quick and dirty hack
to try and get some kind of attention
moving
why didn't they just use self-attention
or some flavor of self-attention this
this was already
you know in the zeitgeist at the time
and uh marcus points out that well
that's exactly what they did
you know not long after the the capsule
networks with em and attention paper
released they they did indeed release
paper that had more transformer
flavor attention that works feed forward
no internal optimization loops
so that was that was our bad there for
not for not researching deep enough in
our defense we
we do a hell of a lot of research for
these these sessions to try and get up
to speed but
you know you do miss things and it's
really hard to stay state of the art on
this sort of stuff and
unless you're very deeply involved so
particularly mia culpa
marcus thank you very much for sending
me straight i'm glad i'm glad that
sanity prevailed in the end though
he also he also points out to some other
literature that's out there
specifically regarding recursive
cortical networks recursive
cortical networks i i don't understand
too well but
basically they're a kind of uh
probabilistic graphical model
that looks at things like closed shirt
shapes and curves instead of like banks
of learned filters
but they still have that capsule net
hierarchy of features kind of concept
baked into them
one of the really cool things about
these recursive cortical networks as
well is that they are
generative models and one of the things
that many folks in the
community are talking about now just
like we did with carl fristen and max
welling
is it's a really cool idea to have a
generative model of the world
and they're an act they're another area
of active research
a full shout out to marcus carr he's
actually doing his thesis
on a variant of these things where he's
actually combining them with the idea of
transformers
and it like the idea sounds pretty cool
they're
you know trying to find a new more
bright more
inclusive attention structure to model
images as
uh to kind of quote him i got it here he
says the the key is to recast image
recognition
as a seek to seek to seek problem
instead of translating between tokens
we translate between sets of learned
queries so
if anyone out there is kind of
interested in capital net research
you know keep an eye out for marcus carr
because this this sounds like an
interesting alternative approach that
certainly
gels with a lot of my experience playing
around with capsule nets
and and alternative cnn architectures
you know the attention-based stuff will
be the way forward
and so i think this is really good i
think this is fantastic
that these hierarchical representation
or this hierarchical representation
literature is an area of active research
because if
nothing else the idea of capsule nets
you know these
the hierarchies of features build
objects
is worth investigating it's a fantastic
idea
the conceptualization of capsule nets as
inverse computer graphics
right if we could get a system working
like that
it would it may not transform academia
and industry overnight but it would
transform it
we would suddenly have a very natural
way of doing image recognition
things like interpretability would just
would would suddenly be a lot easier to
do even in abstract settings
things like understanding why faults
were detected would be
much easier to dissect but
i i want to kind of i want to kind of
expound on something here
we marcus and i personally
like i i haven't discussed this with you
know yannick or tim
but like i think me and marcus see
things very similarly
in that you know there's potential here
and it's the problems are being worked
out
and that this is an exciting area worthy
of continued research
my problem with capsule nets
particularly
i'm going to pick on capturing that's
with the m routing here but it's a
problem that's common to the
what was it called capsule nets with
dynamic routing
the the earlier paper um with vector
value capsules
it's it's not that you know they're
trying to build this system
because i think the system is great it's
what they claim that they're doing
now in the case of the
capsules with em routing paper they
claim that
because they're using 4x4 matrix value
outputs
that they're doing things with the pose
of objects within the image
and that's simply false that's
just not true the matrices that they're
using have no particular internal
structure
so really this is just you know this is
just a collection of
equations being transformed arbitrarily
if
if they were acting in the way that
hinton claimed there would only be six
degrees of freedom in the system
pose matrices only have six degrees of
freedom you know
three for translation three for rotate
three for rotation
in three dimensions and certainly you
know
it it's not the case that just throwing
four by four matrices
in gives you these properties
in in general these sorts of geometric
transformations live on
things called lead groups which are kind
of like smooth manifolds
in the space of 4x4 matrices that can
only take on restricted values because
they do describe these physical things
and therefore
the the range of potential values is is
rather limited
and my problem with a lot of this
research is that these
big claims are made hey we're doing this
you know our
our whiz-bang new regularization
technique works because of x y and z
but there's no proof of it there's
there's no proof
and there's no real evidence sometimes
you get something like uh
in the original capsule nets paper they
they you know showed oh well if we tweak
this value we get translation
but if they tweaked another value the
tail of the seven wobbled around so like
you know they were saying oh it's
encoding this this spatial information
well is it
or is that just something that happened
to be learned
from from how i view it it's not enough
to just apply a penalty
and say oh therefore it should be doing
this it's like no you you gotta
you gotta bind it to do these things
otherwise it
it's not working the way that you say it
is and a lot of
a lot of research seems to be barreling
up blind alleys based on hunches of
researchers that
that didn't prove what they were saying
was true
so yeah i i don't want to i don't want
to go too much
into too much depth on um
you know the failings of or what i see
is the failings of these papers
because they did they do do some really
cool things like for instance switching
to vector-valued functions
i think that's brilliant because moving
to vector value
functions on any given point means you
can do things like
get these geometric matrices and start
to do like transformations or stuff
and this shows up a lot in max welling's
research theme on
on group equivarian transformations or
like
gauge equivariance and stuff where you
do need that
vector to kind of live in some space and
to transform according to some set of
coordinates
fine right that's that's that's just
cricket as far as i'm concerned
the problem that i really have is is
that you know
um a 4x4 matrix does not oppose matrix
make
and anyone should have called out
jeffrey hinton on that
because it's nowhere does he show that
that that's actually what's happening
any even if it is happening it's
happening by accident
not not because the optimization problem
kind of constrains to that
but yeah but that kind of i guess
quibble
on theoretical points aside i i'd really
like to thank mark scar for writing in
you know he he set us straight i really
hope to speak to him soon
and when his thesis is coming together a
little bit more maybe we'll get him to
show out to walk us through
his his proposed architecture because
you know if
again if we can get this working it's
it's good news for all of us
anyway next in the show we have one of
our community members alex
matic he's talking to us today about
type theory
now he says that type theory is the
study of the dependence of types
terms and values to construct systems
that allow for formal reasoning
about a program's correctness run time
memory safety and other attributes
or even formally define the whole
constructive mathematics
so due to that type theory becomes a
powerful tool for a computer scientist
to reason about the complex
issues that are inherent when building
big software applications
either automatically or
semi-automatically
so alex believes that the classical
techniques of computer science
specifically type theory
is a necessity for continued progress in
mathematics computer science
artificial intelligence and machine
learning even though deep learning which
mostly relies on empirical evidence and
rarely on formal proofs and type theory
which basically solely relies on formal
proofs
they seem to be polar opposites in his
view and a lot of opportunities arise
from combining them together
namely that automatic proofs can allow
for more insight into the inner workings
of deep learning systems that will not
be possible for human understanding
alone
and due to the fact that a sufficiently
strong type system does not allow for
constructing terms that do not match the
function's exact type
neural networks can be used to generate
functions that
by design have certain properties
without having to rely on the neural
networks to be
formally correct so he says that this
can be used to further increase type
theory's power
by using the curry howard correspondence
which is
if a neural network can generate a
function it thereby
can also generate proofs which can be
used to gain an even
deeper understanding of types and
therefore computer science and
mathematics
anyway it was a real honor to have alex
join us today
and it goes to show that we've got a
really vibrant community in our discord
and please join our discord
and if you would like to have a
conversation with us we only have three
rules
you need to be smart articulate and
opinionated
and as you can see alex has those three
properties in
spades enjoy after the conversation alex
also created this pdf file which i'll
link in the description
uh formalizing some of the things that
we were talking about so you know a term
rewriting system
what confluency means
we talked about polymorphism so there's
an example here in haskell
also talking about the calculus of
constructions
so yeah go and check out this pdf file
after you've watched the video so um
alex great to meet you
yep thank you thank you for having me
pleasure
so um anyway alex we got introduced to
you because you are
an aficionado of data types
i wouldn't quite say that but i know my
way around
so i know as i know enough to
basically explain a lot of motivation
behind type theory and
why we should use it and why it's also
an interesting
research direction for com for not only
computer science but also
machine learning and artificial
intelligence not only as
a tool to use but also as a thing to
explore
so what's the state of the art of
definition what is a type
oh so a type is
a way to write down the semantics
so i'm going to stay inside the realms
of computer science there is
there are basically two big directions
that uh type theory is
going at the moment one is more focused
on
computer science and one is more focused
on like defining the fundamentals of
mathematics
they're both very similar but at the
moment
at least in like this general sense
there is a problem of unifying both of
them
so i'm going to keep in the computer
science
around because that's also a little bit
easier and
in this state you could you could say
that
type is just a semantic for lambda
calculus
or any syntactic foundation for computer
science
so in if you have a computer
and you still have an entire computer
regardless of what it's based on if it's
based on like an actual machine or
lambda calculus and you tell them i have
two things execute addition on them
it will do that regardless of whether
the two things you want to add
are actually integers or they are
floating points
the mechanics will still work the same
the thing is you will just get an
output which is not what you wanted
so the way to remedy that is you define
what do you semantically want for
example in the addition of integers you
say
i want an integer and another integer
and then i
give you well another integer
and this has the advantage of not being
able to get into the situation where you
for example start adding floating points
and booleans
like for example how it's possible in
like c or
assembly language where you can do all
of that i'm naive to this but it sounds
like you're describing a kind of
template
personally speaking i think that there's
a difference between the type
in like an object-oriented setting and a
functional setting
what we usually talk about is in the
what's happening is that both of them
are
close to the same so that's why the
analogy with templates is also close to
perfect
the main difference and it's also the
thing you lose when you walk
from a like object-oriented language
into a function language is
you basically lose the option of calling
by reference
so you can still do template functions
in c plus plus i'm not quite sure how
they work
so don't don't worry about that i know
how they work uh super well
i'm uh i'm the keyplus plus master so we
can go to that route we can talk about
it but
in object-oriented languages what we can
do is we can define
for example a car and then change
things on top of it so we can say
braking
reduces the speed by well how much you
break
the you can also do that in functional
programming that's basically what a
monarch is used for
you you change something of the state
and what you get is you get back an
object with that change state
the difference is in opposite-oriented
programming
you don't have to return the thing but
you change
what it once was so it's not like a
function in like the mathematical sense
we
input an x and it becomes a different y
you morph the x to become a y
that's difference between object
oriented programming and
functional programming let's can we go
back though because i'm still not
satisfied that i know what a type is
let's start with i think lambda calculus
is a good place to start because it's uh
you know relatively simple if you will
um or
i find it to be probably one of the
simpler
or easier to understand definitions of
computing right so
for those out there that aren't familiar
with lambda calculus and maybe
we'll put up a graphic if this comes up
but you know
it's it's a rewriting scheme so you have
these variables
right and they're represented by symbols
let's just call them x
y and z and you write down what are
called
functions and these just take the form
of
lambda which is like just say a symbol
right and then parentheses and then a
list of variables like
x y okay and then you give what the
result
of the application the symbolic
application of the
that rule to those symbols are so you
might say for example
lambda of x y is equal to x
star x plus x star y
so you're just rewriting those symbols
with this this kind of new
list of symbols and there's some other
little bits in there and you can look it
up on the wikipedia but that forms kind
of a turing complete
model of computation go ahead can i ask
the dumb question so
i've seen lambda style functions in
almost every language these days there's
a lot of cross-pollination in languages
whether it's
r or javascript or python or c sharp um
it's just a function right yes in my
opinion yeah
they're they're right there just just to
simplify it
let's maybe start at the beginning with
but there's a good motivation for lambda
calculus and also for types
yeah let's start at the beginning at
term rewriting schemes
so because that's a nice motivation for
lambda calculus and
then for types so a term rewriting
scheme
is just a syntactic basically a rule
that gives you for example in normal
addition
you may have associativity you can
define a rule that says
well if you have something x plus
brackets y plus z you can rewrite that
and move the brackets to the front
so x plus y plus z
so in rewriting terms we
we usually only allow one direction
because if we lower both then we could
get into an
infinite loop so that's one of the
restrictions
now if you look at a term rewriting
scheme
there are two things two properties you
are most often interested in
one is termination as i've just
mentioned basically
if we use a symmetric closure then we
automatically get
a non-terminating argument or terminal
writing scheme
but there are many different ways of
basically getting transitive
infinite loops to prevent that closure
is a function inside a function
a closure is if you have a function
if you have a relation between two
uh two things for example you have an x
and a y for f of
x x equals one and a closure
is just extending the function to be
uh to have a certain property so a
symmetric closure
adds everything that's symmetric to that
relation so
if you have a function x which is a
relation of
a set x y then a symmetrical closure
gives you
y x too so
we should know there's there's kind of
more than one um
there's kind of more than one notion or
concept of closure and so
some people might be familiar with with
the term closure from
scheme or some other programming
language which you know kind of means
like
the state of the function at a certain
point plus all its all its bindings its
environment if you will so there's kind
of different mean
meanings of it and jobs um but yeah
but i think what we were talking about
there in the context of termination i
think
we're talking about probably transit of
closure which is
so if you have if you have a function so
let's just for the moment
imagine a function as as a relation like
in a database sense you know you have
x and y and they're related in some ways
so for example keith knows tim
tim knows alexander that would show up
as keith
followed by tim tim followed by
alexander so keith in the x column
tim and the y column and you know if
if you take that function and apply it
to itself so you join
those two relations so you do like a
join a literal kind of database join
um and then you do the union of kind of
the the new
the new columns then you wind up with an
expanded set so if i know tim
and tim knows alexander then by second
second knowing i know alexander type
thing and you can keep repeating this
and eventually if it terminates i.e the
relation like no longer keeps growing
larger and larger and larger then that
is the transitive closure
of that of that function it contains
like
the you know the result of applying that
function to itself
forever until it stops producing you
know new
new stuff so am i right about that but
just
because you said that's the transitive
closure but what about this symmetric
closure is that the infinite loop thing
we don't want that yes okay if we
we usually get a trans so what we want
to prevent is we want to prevent a
transitive symmetric closure
that's one of the ways things can get
infinite
because if you have something
that's the magic transitive you can for
example say i go to
from one to two to three and then for
free you can go back to one
and then you have this infinite loop so
that's
one of the ways okay so suppose we've
got like
a rewriting you know rewriting scheme
and in this case
just lambda calculus to make it specific
and by the way tim i just want to point
out something here because this may come
up in a future
future talk is you can think of
rewriting rules
as pattern matching okay so you're
you're examining your current state and
if you find a pattern uh
then you you ex rewrite that as a new a
new set of symbols like you expand the
sim
you expand it into a new set of symbols
so kind of like pattern
match and expand um i don't know if
we're allowed to do contraction and
lambda calculus or not
isn't that very similar because there's
a concept in haskell where you can do
pretty much
what alex just said before right so you
have this pattern which is x
plus brackets y plus z and you can
rewrite that
yep that's basically where i want to go
because
are we alex are we allowed to do like
contraction i don't i don't recall
are you allowed to have a pattern that
that matches and produces like a smaller
pattern because then you can wind up
with these
these circles too well right
i guess uh any given lambda calculus we
don't know if it's going to terminate
is that true like okay because it's a
it's a deciding problem
right exactly so
all right so in this context though
here's my question so we've got we've
got some rewriting rules
um i i think at that point
if you want to add types to land the
calculus
then this is some structure that you
associate with a particular symbol right
or
like you would say that the symbol x
belongs to this
this type and maybe z also is a
is a an element within that the domain
for that type
but what is that that stuff is it like a
set of predicates
that that that uh that elements of that
type satisfy
um you know what exactly is that
when i write it down what is a type so
there's a very unpretty uh notion
because if you have a
type like the natural numbers this is
just a synonym for different type
so um maybe let's back up a bit
with lambda calculus so where was going
with the term rewriting because that's
going to make a lot of things clear the
ish
so if you have a term routing system in
front of you you're usually interested
in two properties
one is termination and one is something
called confluency
confluency means if i have
an equation and i can apply different
rules at different
points so basically i could first
use the associativity rule and then like
commutativity or i can use first
commutativity and then associativity
will i end up at the same normal form
so at the end if i reduce it down
now as it turns out if you actually try
to do that you try to
for example write a symbolic math
library
this is very hard um confluency not as
much
but especially termination so what
people thought about
is well what about if we could
build a term rewriting system
that builds other term rewriting systems
and that's what lambda calculus is in
theory maybe let's take a quick example
we have
an equation that is x plus brackets
y plus 0. if you want to i can also
send you maybe something later so you
have x
plus brackets y plus 0.
you could first go and reduce y plus 0
to y and you get x plus y and
then you have to stop you cannot do any
further on the other hand you can also
say
well let's use associativity and write
x plus y plus 0
and then we use x plus y plus 0
is equal to x plus y so these are all
syntactical slides but in a different
order in this case we even
end up at the same destination and
that's something very important because
if if you have a system that basically
diverges for different
uh orderings of rules then you
basically have to ensure that certain
rules are applied in a certain order
and this is oftentimes not trivial
because
one rule application will maybe lead to
a literal structure which is actually
another rule application
so on that do we need to design these
rules then so because
so you said this confluency means it
doesn't matter which order i apply these
rules but so many things in mathematics
the order does matter for example if i'm
doing matrix transformations
i might do a rotation and a translation
and then an affine transformation
it matters which order i do them in so
doesn't that restrict the operations
that we can
what we're always talking about is
syntactic rewriting
let me just jump in here because i think
there might have been
so let me just check on something so tim
so linear algebra
um you know as you as you rightly point
out there
there's like an order of operations but
if you were to write down a
a lambda calculus for uh
for linear algebra it would respect
those those orders of operations
um you know so for example would say
like okay if i have
matrix a times matrix b i'm not allowed
to rewrite that as
b times a because i you know that yes
that's that's not
a a rewriting rule so that rewriting
rule would never show up in there i
think the confluency problem is that
if you've got this set of rules you do
want to make sure and it's in the
context of anything so linear algebra
you want to make sure that if you
like suppose i write down keys lambda
calculus for linear algebra and i go
around
say look everybody i've written down a
lambda calculus for
linear algebra the confluency
requirement is that if somebody follows
my rules
right that no matter what path they
follow through those
those rules they get to the same they
get to the same result
so there's kind of like a consistent you
know set of linear algebras so imagine
if
linear algebra had a rule that said yeah
well
you know a a times b
you can't change that to b times a but
you can change a times b
times c to a times c times b
right well that would that would kind of
introduce an inconsistency because then
if you
if you apply the rules on some larger
set of equations if somebody decide to
go down that path
rather than some other path they'll wind
up with you know a different answer so
it contains like an
internal um i don't want to say
inconsistency but an internal
what's the opposite of a confluence
divergence yeah it's like an internal
divergence
so these are two properties so
confluency and termination are two
properties we both want
in a germany writing system now
what people figured out is if you just
write down this thing
informally it's very hard to actually
analyze
all of these properties of like a
general term rewriting system
so one thing people people thought well
let's write a term writing system
for a term rewriting system so basically
a matter
system and this is lambda calculus
in lambda calculus we have rules
we introduce them with lambda so for
example a rule
lambda x dot lambda y
dot x y just means well we have an
x and we apply the y uh
to the x in
and as it turns out that's already all
you need
you don't need a plus you don't need the
natural numbers you don't need anything
and the reason for that is the natural
numbers in of itself
are also a system that's based on rules
so if you for example have the natural
let's take natural numbers because the
easiest example
what do you have well we have the zero
and then we have a successor function so
zero one two three are just zero
successor of zero successor of successor
of zero
and so on and as it turns out
it doesn't even actually matter what
zero
is if i
if i write zero as a symbol or if you
write 0
as like a text it still doesn't change
anything
so the natural numbers are defined by
this recursive structure
that's the reason why the lambda
calculus is so simple because
you don't need anything else then i need
to introduce a rule
and i need to apply that rule because
everything else
every structure you can think of has to
have some kind of
rule below it and i i would recommend
listeners when you get the chance if you
haven't before gone to look at
what are called pianos axioms which
define
arithmetic it'll kind of give you you
know the
a very simple way in which to think
about rules or uh you know predicates
that you could write down
functional forms that would that would
define arithmetic and you can write that
as a
as a type you can write that as let's
say an algebraic type
for example there's a you know whole
algebra i think it's correctly called
algebraic type theory right
alex the the sort of one one model of
type theory
what fascinates me about this though
this is the beauty of mathematics that
we see the natural numbers and we almost
assume that these things are just
we don't really have examples of how do
we abstract the rules that apply to
natural numbers
we see something similar in group theory
for example you know what happens if you
take a step up and you look at
different transformations to objects and
you represent that mathematically
it's just beautiful what you can express
in mathematics
oh oh it is so this is the entire field
of
abstract algebra um and it's really cool
you know the
the sort of the way that uh a teacher
once or a professor wants phrases to me
is he said imagine that you were some
alien right and you just showed up at
earth and you started doing
anthropological research to figure out
you know
understand what people are doing right
and and you would just start kind of
you might start associating symbols with
with their kind of
rules and math and you would examine the
structure of those symbols like well
when they have
you know the x equals y when they have
kind of that
that symbol that set of symbols written
down that sentence
it also it often implies that y equals x
also and so we have this kind of rule
there which says like in an abstract
sense any time x is equal to y y is
equal to x
and so they would just start kind of
analyzing and dividing up
our mathematics in this sort of very
abstract symbolic way
and abstract algebra is the study of
what you have
what do you have left over when you kind
of strip all the
you know i guess all the semantics what
do you have left over when you strip all
the semantics
from those symbols x and y and just look
at the patterns and the rewriting and
the
and the and the rules behind there it's
it is fascinating it's really pretty
neat a neat study can be kind of
mind-blowing too actually
it definitely is so what i just said
with the
basically boiling it down to the syntax
that's
really also what's happening and what's
that kind of problem with
lambda calculus because now
we have this beautiful structure you can
write re
rewriting systems in it there are also
other
nice attributes for example confluency
as it turns out
we can basically have solve confluency
with lambda calculus since every term
that does terminate in lambda calculus
is also confluent
so it doesn't matter what thing i've
reduced first and what
thing i read second and we can even do
one better
we can say if we have an infinite amount
of ways to rewrite it so an infinite
amount of orderings
we can find one or we can always find an
ordering
that terminates if it exists so
for example if you have a part of a
function that runs indefinitely
but it turns out i never need to
evaluate it i can find
basically a way to reduce it to
basically reduce around that problem
so this is one of the very nice
attributes of lambda calculus
one of the not so nice attributes is
exactly the lack of semantics
and this and this also leads to the
second problem
because we cannot decide termination
this is also something a little bit to
do with the fact that we cannot
redefine semantics i'm going to be
careful here because
there are ways of defining semantics for
lambda calculus
pure lambda calculus but i don't know
anyone who
actually works with them i think it's i
think it's more like
a thing you can do we should
to obtain confluency you need to
establish
a certain set of rules to ensure
termination because
there are many ways of doing things and
some of them terminate and some of them
don't is is that what you were saying
um not not not really
so in lambda calculus we can assume that
every term that terminates
is also confluent so it's an implication
right but if but termination
the termination is sometimes also
dependent on the order of
operations so there are terms that don't
always terminate but also
only sometimes terminate and for those
we can also find basically the one
reduction strategy
that leads us to a terminating case
termination in our case means every path
terminates
so it doesn't matter which reduction
i take it always terminates and if
that's the case
then we get confluency i see because
that's why i was confused because the
way i understood confluency before
was it shouldn't matter the order in
which
you do the operations in which case it
doesn't really matter which path you
take through
these there's a kind of tree of paths of
operations
and what you're saying is regardless of
the path you take through that tree
um they should all um terminate yes
but hold on so i think to mention
something that we didn't kind of mention
before which is
and i believe this applies here but alex
correct me if i'm wrong
so termination problems like in
computability theory
they have two parts of them they have
the the machine so in this case
it would be the a particular lambda
calculus
here's the set of rules and the input
and then the question is will this
machine
terminate on this on this input like
that's the
the sort of halting problem or the the
decidability problem correct
yes though in lambda calculus we usually
assume that
the inputs are also inside the term
definition
so for example you also get
you get the whole thing with the
arguments applied
and so so therefore we don't need to
have this distinction between
the machine that terminates for certain
input
we just look at does the entire lambda
calculus terminate
because the lambda calculus is already
with inputs in it
right okay so fine so it's just here's
the thing you know does it terminate
and so and just to kind of like tie off
at that end you know the
the quote-unquote halting problem as a
whole
is can you build a machine that given
any machine plus input can determine
whether or not
you know it terminates and like the
answer that question is no
like you can't and there's a for readers
interested you should sometimes look up
the proof to that it's like super simple
it's in like
five lines or something will kind of
blow your mind maybe
i think it's pretty mind-blowing but in
any case i think what
alex is saying is that for a particular
uh and i have to keep making this
distinction you know input plus
machine lan like for a particular lambda
calculus plus it's
its input even though you're saying
that's sort of typically seen as part of
the
definition of it you know if it
terminates
then it's it's confluent is that correct
yes right but i think you were saying
that there could be for that same
lambda calculus there could be an input
for which it doesn't terminate
is that correct um
[Music]
no what i was trying to say is let's say
we have a different
lambda calculus and if you say
termination
we usually mean the all paths terminate
so if it's
entire tree and every path from the tree
terminates
now let's say we get a tree and there
are some paths that do terminate
and there are some other paths who will
go up to infinity
so in this case we can even we can find
the path that does terminate
so basically it's a weakening of this
termination problem
okay so we can find the path it does
terminate and if it terminates
so we can find all the paths that
terminate
and and is it the case that all of those
paths are confluent
uh i'm not sure if you can find all
paths that's
that's something i'm not quite sure of
but probably you can
well what if i find more than one if i
find two am i guaranteed that they're
confluent
yes you're guaranteed okay so i got you
so in lambda calculus
if i find any path that terminates it's
the same as
any other path that terminates yes
okay just before we get on to semantics
we've been talking a lot about gbt3 and
language and of course that has a
similar kind of
i guess you could call it a halting
problem the reason why language is
infinity
is because many paths in that tree do
not terminate
so could you draw a contrast between the
kind of
lambda calculus we're talking about and
a potential system for understanding
language
or is that a bit out there um
i don't think it's that out there
but i also think that's not really the
right question to ask
because
[Music]
in because we're talking to about two
different systems
one is a semantic system so gpt3
at least it tries to work in a semantic
space
and lambda calculus as x as it exists
from the definition doesn't have
semantics
just that syntax what it can now do is
you can try to
give this syntactic
the syntactic system a semantic but
again that's something that types them
do i know you said that
there are ways to add types if you will
to uh to lambda calculus i mean there is
you know
typed lambda calculus for example and i
think you said
you know but nobody really uses those no
no that's that's that's not what i said
oh um sorry that it uh the thing is
a type it's try to continue defining
what type is
a type is a guarantee on
a lambda term mostly basically the
simplest
system is simply type lambda calculus it
just guarantees you
if i input something of a type a you get
back something of a type b
and that's a guarantee so there is no a
i can input that doesn't actually give
me a b
okay when we say input so so again a
lambda calculus is a set of many lambda
rules
right yes so at this point what do we
mean by
input so we're making a statement that
says like a particular symbol
x is of type a right
yes okay and so if if x is of type a
then i guarantee that some other
variables are of a certain type like
if x is of type a then i guarantee that
y
is a type b or what basically yes
where y is the application of some some
rules
maybe what you can try to do is
basically
go into like something like haskell and
the idea there is
also if i have a function for example
addition
i say add a natural number natural
number
and you give me back a natural number
then that's actually a guarantee that
any natural number i input and
so any two natural numbers will give me
another natural number
there is no case that's that says
um i can input for example five and i
don't actually get a natural number out
of it
okay so these are these are the in other
words this is
if we think about the function signature
you know that says
x is of type you know a y's of type b
then z is is a type you know c
so it's that just that kind of statement
is is simply typed lambda calculus
is that correct yes and simply trapped
lambda calculus we
we just don't allow many of the
abstractions
the reason we need this it's similar to
um you know there's the ravens example
in in logic
it's super important to be able to
constrain
systems because the reason why we have
typing in programming is we have compile
time error checking
and we can have a really wonderful
experience in our ide because
we can um reason around the behavior of
a particular program
it it's super important to know that
this particular function
it um adds a real number to a real
number and it gets out
a real number right that that seems
super important
but why do you think it's important it's
important because
let's say we define addition in addition
what we can do is we can define that
inductively we can say
x plus 0 is x and x plus
the successor of z is the same as the
successor of
x plus z so maybe i can also write that
into the video and
now this thing only has meaning if what
i input
actually has some kind of idea what an s
is so as in this case if successor
function
the successor function only exists for
like natural numbers
but don't exist for something like um
a car so
it's a guarantee that things
further down the road don't break
just trying to think of a real world
example we were talking to waleed sabha
about natural language understanding and
we talked about the example the corner
table wants a beer and he said well
i've got some ontology here and i've got
a whole bunch of um
let's say lambda calculus over the
ontology and the table doesn't want a
beer
right the table doesn't want anything
because maybe there's a want function
which is attached to every single object
and um only a human can want a beer
so that gives us an example of we can
perform reasoning over this ontology
because we have this type structure
is is that why we might use this well
let me re let me
ask a question that i think might help
us answer that which is so in
an untyped lambda calculus where you've
just got
you know all these these rules that just
say you have any symbol
uh next you know followed by a plus sign
and any other symbol then you can
rewrite it in this way right
and tightly in the calculus you're
saying that
um you know for this rule if you input
an
integer an integer you get an integer
the reason why that's kind of helpful i
think and this is
where i really need you to help me alex
is that of all the kinds of sets of
rules that are in there
some subset i know i can apply for
example to integers
like not every rule can i apply to
integers just like i can't apply the
successor rule
to a car and so in the like what makes
it useful then
is um you know if i have for example a
function signature that tells me that
the
that the result is a real number
then i know it makes sense for me to
apply other rules that take real numbers
as as inputs so i can take you know like
uh
i can't i can't do the square root for
example because if i do the square root
i might get back a complex number and
that that's not
acceptable within that that function so
it it constrains the functions that i
can apply
within within that evaluation if you
will
because i have to end up with a result
that is that is a real number or i could
apply square root
as long as i follow that up with a uh
you know
an ab say um uh you know a a um
magnitude function right um so i think
it
it sort of sets constraints on the code
or the sequences of rules that you can
apply
within a function because you have to
meet the final
constraint that the result be a real
number or an integer or whatever
is that are we going in the right
direction or what yes
it basically says if i get inputs of a
certain shape
i get an output of another shape
so in the case of an integer for example
for
addition i get something that's the
shape of an integer another shape of an
integer and i get back another shape of
an integer
and that's a guarantee so sometimes for
example you hear people
say that an hasker program if it
compiles it works
so it cannot crash that's exactly what
they mean by it
because the type you write down is the
actual guarantee
that what you wrote is a general
statement
for every integer right but the reason
that that's helpful
is that once i've once i've said that a
a symbol has a particular type and then
in a simply type landing
lambda calculus i'm assuming that every
rule
specifies its sort of type signature
which is that
you know this this variable maybe it has
an untyped
possibility too i mean that's fine but
basically every signature says that
this argument is of this type this
argument is of this type and and when i
rewrite it it ends up
of this type and so so you can check
that
like with a quote-unquote compiler you
can look at a particular
function signature and you can look at
the the rules that it applies and you
can
confirm just by all this kind of pattern
matching
whether or not it is at least uh
uh type compatible like that the shapes
are all compatible like almost like
almost the analogy could be with with
shapes and machine learning where i know
i have a
multi-dimensional array that has you
know this certain shape
and if i apply this transformation i get
this shape and you can check all the
shapes
you know straight out of the box without
actually kind of running the algorithm
even
with lambda calculus can you have
inheritance or
interfaces for example could could i
have a a signature which
took in an eye quackable so it took in
as long as something that quacked
did you see what i mean because the
alternative would be what if we had this
inheritance hierarchy
of of a duck you know which was an
animal and we
got ourselves caught up in knots yes you
can
but you can't in simply type limit
calculus so there are
different extensions to this simply type
lambda calculus
one of the obvious ones is polymorphism
so you don't say
this works for like an integer it works
for
anything i put into it so for example
the identity function
that that takes an a and gives you back
an a
that works for any function it doesn't
matter what i input
so hold on like i'm not my my
understanding of
polymorphism was more that i can i can
say
you know i have this functional form and
if x and y are integers then z
is an integer if x and y are are reals
then
z is a real if x and y are one is an
integer and one is a real
then y is real like at least that's
parametric polymorphism right
because it sounded more like what you
were describing was just back to untyped
like i get this
i get this thing and it's any type any
um and then the result is type any
because my understanding of polymorphism
with that um i quackable example
is it could take in any type so it it
might be a mallard duck or it might be
some other type of duck
but they are all i quackable so
essentially it's polymorphism
um so
[Music]
so there are two extensions that usually
go
hand in hand one is this polymorphism
which just says um
every this is guaranteed for every type
so it's different from untapped damper
calculus because it's still
a guarantee of termination so in
and in
what the next extension could be is
we add we add a thing that's basically a
type of a type
so you just mentioned interfaces you can
also do that
so uh the important part is to
actually produce a consistent system we
have to make sure that an
interface is something completely
distinct from
a type so this is just but this is our
technicality
so in haskell for example you have type
classes
so you could write like a class that's
quackable
and this has a function gets called
quack
and then you can say well this well a
duck
implements this class so it's basically
part of this group of types
and then you can also request in your
like
polymorphic function you can request
you can request a function a value that
has this attribute so
these are usually seen as two different
extensions
so you have one is polymorphism a
guarantee that's for all types
and the second is basically types of
types
and together you have this system where
you can have
we can plug out a certain subset of
types for which
a function has a guarantee so what's the
what's the highest order
form of lambda calculus called the one
that includes like
every consider every extension so long
as they all remain
mutually consistent what's it called
like ultra tight calculus or what
it's the calculus of constructions the
calculus of constructions
okay so i have to read up on that later
we we
lose the we lose the name with like type
we use the type three part because
it's way more than that uh the calculus
of construction is powerful enough to be
busy a foundation for mathematics
so and that's also what people are
trying to do they try to do basic get
away from like using
a set it's like the baseline definition
for math
they try to use this for example
calculus of constructions or
homotropy type theory or something like
that and
basically with this with these two
extensions i've already mentioned we are
already very close to
this cactus constructions the third
extension so
you need is you need to be able to put a
value inside of a type
so or a function basic values and
functions lambda hackers are the same
so and this becomes very interesting
because now you can define something
like a matrix type
which is like a matrix which takes in
two real values
and an m and then you can for example
define matrix multiplication by saying
well give me a matrix with the
dimensions n and
m another matrix with the dimensions m
and c and i get out a
matrix with dimensions n and c and then
is that is that generalizable to where
like m and c could just be arbitrary
functions so i
if i take a matrix that satisfies
function m
and function c and another matrix that
satisfies function in
and function x that the end result
satisfies function g is is it that
general
um in other words where it's not just a
value like it's not just a a simple
value but an actual function that um
that sort of you know is true or false
for that
well presumably you could you could
define anything you wanted it
you can even generalize the matrix to
have your own custom basis functions
right so essentially a constraint system
a contract system if you will
like it is it general enough to to
provide for that
it's general enough to do basically
anything you can think of in math
so because i'm taking a word for this so
if i if i go
if i really wanted to educate myself on
the state of the art of where we're at
these days with this
and if i start diving into calculus of
construction
that's where i should start right um
i'm not sure if calculus of construction
is the right place to start
learning about type theory but
what i mean is that uh that if i if i
delve into that field i'll be getting
state of the art is there any and i and
and again i'm just making sure i i get
the whole landscape here
is there any competing sort of field
like there's the calculus of
construction guys and they're in this
side of the conference and over on the
other side are the
the something else that like think
they're completely wrong
and have a different is is there
something like that what's that so
so i don't think anyone really says that
the thing is completely wrong
there are different ways to think about
types
so the calculus construction is one way
and what people are now trying to do is
there's another
idea in type theory which is called
homotherapy type theory
which basically acts as if every type
is a point in a topology
topological space and has connections
between them
and if type 1 and type 2 has a
connection
that goes into both directions then they
are the same and as it turns out this is
very useful
in like to define basically math two
what people are trying to do is they try
to do basically
calculus of constructions and try to
basically find a way to
get this homotropic type theory get a
computational
element inside of it and as
it turns out it's more difficult than
one might think okay so but
does does category theory fit within
calculus of construction yes okay all
right cool
so that i'm satisfied then now i've got
something fun to uh study
over this holiday break we've got nine
minutes left and we
would be doing ourselves a disservice if
we didn't contrast all of this
wonderful world to deep learning because
deep learning is the complete opposite
of this what we've been talking about
is imbuing knowledge into
systems right and this is the way that
you know the good old-fashioned ai folks
used to do
it because we're talking about knowledge
i think with lambda calculus right
deep learning is the complete opposite
we're just working in arbitrary
geometric spaces and we don't really
understand what on earth is going on
do you do you think we should be
introducing some of these these ideas
into deep learning
i definitely think so the issue we have
in deep learning is
we can't use it for anything mission
critical because
i don't want i probably i wouldn't even
want to have a car which is completely
deep learning based
because i have no idea of what will it
do if it gets in the situation
that isn't in the training set so
what we actually want is we want formal
guarantees
in the okay in the perfect case we
usually don't even get former guarantees
at the moment
but in a perfect case i would want to
have a car that drives and is formally
correct
in the sense that um
that certain guarantees are always
intact so for example is i'm guaranteed
to always stay on the road
and one one way you could basically
introduce
type theory to deep learning is by
saying
well in type 3 a lot of things involve
proofs so i haven't really touched on
that but
there is something called the curry
howard is morphism and it basically
tells us that a type
is just a statement and
the basic function is a proof for that
statement
so if i have a statement that says uh
for example i have a value for all of
which for example have a number
and every other number is bigger than
that number
then writing a program that
basically gives me this value is akin to
proving that statement and
as it turns out this proves over time
and type 3 get
more and more and more involved and get
more complicated more complex
and also more general so i do want to i
do want to be fair to
machine learning so the sort of provable
correctness of um of software for
example
we don't have that today so i mean today
what we do but there's very
there's only a very microscopic domain
of of software writing like in some of
the
some of the things that nasa does for
example you know they may have provably
correct
uh algorithms or pieces of code that
they've taken the time to do that
and so sort of somebody from the machine
learning you know side could argue look
the benchmark here isn't provable
correctness it's more human
human level correctness because humans
screw up software all the time
i mean we suffer from it every day and
you know in fact you know people die
from it
so um we just have to get to a point
where machine learning is
much better than human parody and then
you might
you might be willing to drive a car that
was totally deep learning based
if we have evidence that shows you know
it's better than people
99 point however many nines kind of
percent of the time
so but but i agree with you that that
that
if we do want to get towards a a realm
in which we have more provably correct
um
software we we need something like this
we need something like
you know tight type systems
and so to excel no further
the idea that you can use machine
machine learning
for like form of proofs is something i
found very interesting
because even in for example in i think
it was 2016 we had alphago
which basically had a simulator and then
did monte carlo research and just
basically looked at which paths are
worth exploring more
and this three is something that's also
very useful for like formal proofs
if i have um if i have like
something i want to prove and i have
many different options i can take
and you could think of a deep learning
system that basically
decides in which order i can explore
them so basically do
like a heuristics function learn that
and
as it turns out this is probably
possible
even now with our current understanding
of
uh machine learning and it's something i
think it's probably under
underexplored because it's that as
has the opportunity to be basically a
step
forward in like software engineering
overall in computer science overall
can you expand what you mean by a
heuristic function and by the way it's
not just
alphago and we're talking about gbt3 we
might need to have a kind of monte carlo
tree search to search for gbt3
i knew you were going to mention that i
always bring it back to gpt3
but but what do you mean by a heuristic
function
a heuristic function is something that
weighs paths
based on basic own smell so if i have
10 paths and one of them it kind of it
seems better than the other ones
i take that one function that we think
correlates to the true objective
function it's like a rule of thumb
yeah exactly because this is the problem
we have a gt3 i personally think it's
not doing anything interesting
but then we have connolly he who says
well we just need we need what alphago
did we need to do this multi-college
research
clearly there exists a path through this
space of possibilities which is super
interesting
and we need some kind of a controller on
the top now
all right that's a rabbit hole i do want
to say thank you so much
uh alex for your education here and i
think we should i think we should talk
more
absolutely i think this has been an
amazing uh uh conversation actually and
um it's a really cool idea actually
because we've got this amazing discord
community on on yannick's server and
we've got some incredibly bright people
like alex and
the only rule to come on street talk is
is to be
uh smart articulate and opinionated and
alex has got all of
all of those three in spades so alex
thank you we're not gonna have a
civility rule we're not gonna have a
the only reason i hate chromium is
there's a developer called glenn
he used to do dhtml about 20 years ago
and
he is the person who has single-handedly
forbidden
um chromium from supporting mru tab
switching
so this is the default behavior in
basically every single windows
application
is in vs code everywhere and he
said he basically killed it from the
beginning there's like a on the chromium
bug tracker there's a thing which has
been closed it's been there it's for ten
years
it's had about five thousand people say
what the [ __ ] why can't we have mru tab
switching
and it's because of this one guy what's
mru
switching most recently used tab
switching when you go controlled
like if you do alt tab on your operating
system or even the ios does it
everyone does this what the [ __ ] holy
[ __ ] doesn't even box on a linux
yeah but they do the carousel thing
which is so stupid because i've got 100
tabs open
but what am i going to do do control tab
100 times is there stories about
fischer the statistician being exactly
because you know why because he he
wasted so much of my time
because i had to go through this crap
orthodox statistic
education that then ended up being
totally useless and only to accidentally
discover
the probability theory is logic
viewpoint decades later or
whatever 10 years later that actually
was useful and understandable i just
felt like i got
ripped off in my education because of
that guy
we are here to talk about reader mail i
never managed to finish to write
this was about one episode where
you were it was a keep until episode
and parts of my and the things i wanted
to talk about
that i don't think we should pre-encode
information and information into our
models
and also some theories i have about
label information density
and why cnn models are basically
learning garbage or image models
and before we start i want to say right
off the bat that
there's a really good chance i will be
wrong with everything
that's okay wrong about everything join
the crowd
pre-encode information because we were
talking all about um inductive
priors and there's a bias variance
trade-off so the idea is that if you
don't put
inductive price into models then it's
very difficult to learn stuff
it's actually a really good argument
give me
just a concrete example of a model that
encodes
no information
i can't i cause in my mind like i can't
even write down
anything without encoding like even if i
tried some
non-parametric as possible approach
somehow i'm going to
imply information about the domain that
it's integers or it's a real number
between here and there
there's always some kind of
of prior information encoded and like
any
formula or or workable process that i
write down
i was more specifically talking about
about you mentioning that you maybe want
what to see
something like rotational invariants
encoded into vision models
and i would and the idea behind was that
maybe you can approximate some function
with a million
values but it would be smarter to find
this one function that would
that we are trying to approximate
and i would say and and
i would say that we should go in the
opposite direction and try to remove
as much biases out of our models
because yeah i am on i'm of the opinion
that we should learn from data
not from the models let's do the let's
let's run through that then
the reason why we introduced biases into
deep learning models presumably the
blank slate model is the fully connected
network
but the problem is we waste the
representational capacity because we
just memorize everything
the cnn is a great inductive prior and
that gives you translational weight
sharing
so it models local connectivity
it also allows you to reuse the same
weights across many parts of the image
giving you translational variants and
meaning that you can learn the same
object in different
parts of the plane and
you're just using the same parameters
over and over again so it gives you
regularization it increases your
generalization it improves your sample
efficiency
your agenda it seems like a good thing
right
that's one of the things that i think we
talked with what was the maxwelling
about
is that so yes it's a good thing but i'm
also
of the opinion that you hard code this
translation in variants and
that's just not always the case it's a
good
bias if you don't have enough data or
compute but
actually the world isn't translationally
invariant
and especially the data sets we have
aren't it
makes sense almost to say
if we had enough data and compute
then you would rather not have these
biases in your model
and fit in that cam there are contexts
in which translation and variance is
correct if i'm looking for a if i'm
looking for a quarter
and all i know is that people are
sending me pictures of quarters that can
occur at any
magnification and it's going to be
anywhere within the picture
then i'm looking for quarters and they
are translationally invariant
if i move a quarter around and i'm
leaving out all there's always details
yeah there's reflected light maybe some
of the reflections change if i
move it around but the ideal quarter is
translationally invariant
and so for that particular application i
would want to have
not only a translationally invariant but
a scale and variant for
zoom and variant whatever you want to
say but you want the deep learning model
to be equivalent though and a big part
of that is not just the sample
efficiency
well it is a little bit but it's about
making it more learnable
from a problem-solving perspective you
come and you hire
a data scientist to write a black box
that determines whether or not there's a
quarter
in the image okay and you've got yannick
and he does it with
25 million parameters and no prior
knowledge built into that and
and tim that comes along and builds in
uses a cnn because he wants
translational invariants and
whatever at the end of the day tim's
going to win like he's going to produce
the black box that
meets that challenge more efficiently
with
better utilization of data power
consumption et cetera
than yannick's black box this was what i
talking about
near-term solutions with more simple
problems
where having inductive bias can be a
good thing but i was more thinking
more long-term in the more 10-year range
with
with much larger data sets and basically
solving computer vision
and in this case i would say
inductive biases are more more harmful
than helpful
i would go completely the opposite way
to you having spoken to walid suburb the
other week
i'm coming around to the view that no
deep learning model can understand
anything so you need to encode
world knowledge into all of these models
because it's
not in the data i've been some middle
ground between you two i think it's all
context dependent even in the case of
ten years from now
okay if we're in a context in a
situation
where there is prior you know knowledge
that we have
whether it's scientific we know that
we're looking at whatever lorenzen
variant
star has or whatever the case is if we
have prior knowledge
no matter what the compute is no matter
what the data size is
someone encoding accurate prior
knowledge
will always have an advantage over
someone encoding
complete ignorance the disadvantage
comes in and yannick has mentioned this
before that if you encode
inaccurate prior knowledge then you're
going to
perform worse and that i think is where
you have to be clever about
what i call providing outs to the
algorithm which is
okay maybe i assign a prior probability
of one-half to my encoded
prior knowledge and then i also have a
one-half probability that i'm totally
wrong and that and so you run kind of
two models in parallel i've got the
ignorance one that knows
basically nothing except the simple
structure of
something has to know something it can't
start with zero there's some simple
structure over there
and then that's one of my prior models
and then the other prior model is this
one that has some stuff encoded
maybe i have some other one like some
different information encoded
and then you do the model waiting
selection routine like i think that
approach always wins out over any pure
no prior knowledge versus prior
knowledge all the time
because a key concept for learning is
generalization this is what francois
chalet pointed out
and if you do take a blank slate
approach
memorization is not good enough you need
to learn something that generalizes and
in order to do that
i would argue you need to have invariant
or equivalent mechanisms inside your
priors
isn't gpt3 against that no i mean what
was
so yannick you said isn't i missed
something gpt is a
counter example to what claim
so we were saying that we're talking
about having all these inductive priors
and so on
gpt3 seems to be an example of a blank
slate
architecture with no inductive priors
really
in in my opinion and i think we all have
slightly different opinions on this but
having played with gpg3 extensively
i am extremely disappointed and i think
it's testament to the fact
that blank slate models have their
limitations
really is it that disappointing for me
i think it doesn't demonstrate any
natural language understanding
whatsoever
i think it's been misrepresented in in
the popular media because people don't
understand that you
sample it randomly so it's not really
appropriate for these prompt engineering
or this software 3.0 stuff
and all of the examples we've seen
online of software 3.0
we have found out that they've been
cherry-picked
and what they've actually done is
they've let gpt3 complete
the software program for them so it's
not really a software program it's
basically just something that gpt3 has
found on the internet
oh yeah i'm admitted i'm a bit less a
bit less
less pessimistic than tim on this i
think it's pretty awesome
maybe i also think we're not good enough
yet that's
asking it questions but it is true that
a lot of these examples are
quite challenging and yeah this performs
actually
exceptionally well at certain things
like it can
generate still it can interpolate
patterns
extremely well it can generate extremely
it can story tell
like storytelling i was amusing stories
that's for sure but i think where we run
into problems is exactly what tim's
pointing out
is when you have people that have an
agenda
and they use cherry picking and
selective biases and kind of things and
they're not careful about
telling that story they're just throwing
stuff out here look it i created a
database and that's the problem is and
we're always going to have that we're
always going to have people with agendas
that hype on
both sides like ai is going to destroy
us oh you're a [ __ ] ai poses no threat
the truth is somewhere in between
so i just liked kenneth's point which is
look it's a playground
and i also like the point that he
brought up of he doesn't understand why
so many people are out there
trying to destroy or diminish gpt-3 but
the answer to that is because there's so
many people out there
over hyping it and so there's a natural
tendency to want to rebalance that
from some one thing i
want to say about gpt3 is i don't think
it's really about the actual
performance this model shows it's more
about the
trajectory as such a technique
lays in front of us and then it's of
course
quite interesting what much larger scale
models will
bring to the table we've got to consider
efficiency here
right there is an efficiency argument
that with gbt3 it does
a few shot learning that's the most
exciting thing about it
it does insane pattern matching with
just a few examples
and even a non-technical user
i'm talking about if not only efficiency
of what's
like scoring or post training
capabilities but you have the efficiency
of its actual
calculation and space con uses and cpu
and how much it took to train it and how
much it learned from the data that it
was provided
there's a good chance that we can
distill and compress the model
so make a much smaller model do pretty
much the same thing and there is an
asymmetry in the sense that we train it
once
and then it's got many downstream
applications i think jan is
representing what some of the miri guys
think which is that intelligence is a
generating function and that their
position is that human intelligence
um is actually not too dissimilar to
gbt3 we're just like a random generator
of some kind
so i warned you in an episode that at
some point we're going to define
intelligence in such a way that people
aren't intelligent
yeah and it's really interesting because
i i actually like entertaining
this idea that many of the things we do
are more procedural than we realize
for example we're very economic in the
decisions we make we look to the
decisions of
others like when we when we turn right
in traffic we don't think about it
because the guy in front of us is doing
it or if there isn't a guy in front of
us we remember when we last did it
and actually almost everything we don't
really think about it because we've just
memorized it
and it's almost like we're just drones
we're just following a script
no i i get it that's why i think
eventually definitions becomes not
useful
but it does come back to system two so
the whole thing that we supposedly have
is this higher level of reasoning and
clearly gbt3 doesn't have it it's just
procedural it's just pattern matching
and i think what jan's possibly trying
to argue here is that actually
intelligence
doesn't have that system too yes
and in the con in the final conclusion
of this part i mentioned that
if we use humans as a benchmark and we
are
we are not that intelligence we are not
that
intelligent we maybe need to
to accept that other systems we don't
perceive it as intelligence as maybe
also so
this is the reader mail from yan let's
change gears for a moment
and talk about intelligence i'm of the
opinion that the level
of human intelligence is vastly
overestimated by humans
and nearly all of it is just us
repeating learned behavior
the only thing that we are capable of
almost exclusively
is interpolating between existing
knowledge and skills
let's look at wozniak's coffee cup test
for example charlay
talked about this in the measure of
intelligence when a human walks into a
random kitchen and tries to make a cup
of coffee
the human is not learning any new skill
but instead just interpolating between
the knowledge
of coffee and a general user interface
experience and some general assumptions
about kitchens
i think that from chile's proposed
formulas they're generally still useful
in that humans have a much
lower g factor than a lot of people
would think so jan says he agrees with
charles
in that society is a form of
decentralized intelligence but i'd like
to rephrase it to
society is the data source of human
intelligence
he says let's look at the invention of
the wheel it is for us
modern humans quite obvious that wheels
exist and how they work
still it took thousands of years for
someone to come up with it
it is to assume that each individual has
a minuscule random exploration chance
and if these new ideas and concepts are
better
then they'll be added to society and the
next generation of people can use it as
training data
jan says he still thinks that humans are
intelligent and he would like to use
them as a baseline
because humans are not intelligent as
most people think
we have to accept that other solutions
are also intelligent
he would also like to address that gpt-3
the model is much less data efficient
than a human baby learning about the
world
and he had he attributes this fact
partially to a highly efficient
evolutionary pruning
of human brains that happened over
billions of years of evolution
and a highly optimized learning
algorithm strictly speaking
both the models and stochastic gradient
descent we use are highly general
functions
and can be applied to many problems the
human brain has probably lost this level
of generality
and is much more efficient at learning
in the real world so jan says he doesn't
necessarily see it as a downside
that our learning models are more
applicable but to
achieve human level intelligence we must
surpass the human brain parameter count
by the amount of training data by some
orders of magnitude
he partially attributes it to much more
information dense data in the form of
multiple
sensory inputs to update our internal
world models
for example a baby can feel a ball can
see the shape of it can see the color
can smell it
can taste it can feel the temperature
and that's the end of jan's letter
yep yeah it is that is actually an
interesting point the
the point that we maybe we should not
compare the exact parameter
efficiency of some like a machine
learning model
to the one of the human brain but maybe
we should normalize it
by the amount of different problems it
is applicable to
that is it that is that i i don't think
i've heard that yeah that makes a lot of
sense because
we can do sgd with neural networks on
things that humans are good at right
like vision and
text and speech but we can also
do them on things that human are crap at
and and it will also solve these
problems and it's such a general
algorithm so
to then to to say maybe because it's so
general we should also
accept the fact that it might need a few
more parameters to achieve the same
the same things so it makes a lot of
sense to me
humans are not really that good at
identifying objects
just still have error quote they are not
that good at
writing text or a lot of other tasks
and we had in 10 20 years ago
when the the things we could come up
with there are some
some encoding of some chess algorithms
or chess
ideas to to beat some russians
if we had to fight this idealized idea
of human intelligence
humans do things really badly like
reading textbook or writing text
yes i would argue we do things
incredibly well what's interesting is
that we do have priors we have cognitive
priors
and chalet pointed this out in his paper
he said that
there's a lot of anthropocentric worldly
things that we are very good at
and he gave the example of travelling
salesman problem we're quite good at
that
but when the number of cities increases
we get quite bad at it or we're good in
three dimensions bad in four dimensions
so comparing uh perfect human against
against a neural network model is also a
bit unfair this was my point
but again it doesn't feel like we're
comparing apples
and apples because i'm sometimes i catch
myself every time i look
at something like a black towel on the
floor for a millisecond i'll think it's
my cat
and then i'll just immediately correct
myself and because we have this
our consciousness has this weird
reflexive
continual it has a loop in it you know
what i mean like neural networks are
just left to the way that our brains
work is
in cycles and we're constantly doing
error correction and we're
reasoning on system two and we don't
even notice
the errors because we have so many
levels of correction do you know what i
mean
we could now move on to my second point
and this was label information density
for that cnn's are basically learning
garbage features and i
have to agree but i think
the reason why they are learning garbage
features is more
that that the input we are giving is
also garbage i'm not surprised that
if we feed garbage and we get garbage
out
and this is the label information
density we are providing the model
that we have that we are for example
with image classifier we are only
giving the model a one-hot
representation
this is this class and we are ignoring
everything else in the image
i now wanted to talk about uh the pixel
level information
so if this is what i wanted to okay and
i i know they are something like a
bounding box the detectors
and labels and also and also semantics
separation tasks and labels and
they are better but i would say they are
by far not optimal
i can decompose the object into smaller
objects for example if i
look at this smartphone
i i can see a smartphone but i can also
see is
a screen i can see some speakers i can
see a camera so i have objective
decomposition
and for capabilities i would say
we should do is having a
multi multi pixel label information
the pixel can be part of a car but then
more specifically can be part of an
engine block
and more specifically can be part of a
screw
and i attribute it to that we are
that's the information label density we
are providing the models is just not
high enough
i would argue that's barking up the
wrong tree because
what the problem is these inductive
priors do not have the concept of
objectness
so you're still scratching around with
individual pixels and how they're
connected to their neighbors
surely a better prior would be able to
understand physical objects and how
they're related to each other and
whether they're connected
i would say that this information would
be also encoded if you
if you would exhaustively describe
the pictures of the real world that how
objects are related
would be then also encoded
if you think about humans we
also just work on the gridded pixel
thing
and and we we just infer objects from
that right
yeah but we have um understanding so we
can do all sorts of reasoning that a cnn
couldn't do
i'm not so sure i'm not so sure your
visual system
is much of an understanding machine more
than just
like a i don't think you do much
understanding in vision
right then maybe later but as you say
it's
when i see my black towel i think it's a
cat i think that is like
automatic and and you're just looking at
these pixels and your brain is like
cats
yeah but then it seems to give away that
there are levels of processing
so it's almost like my pattern matching
brain says cat
and then i have some reasoning and i say
well it can't possibly be a cat
for whatever reason and i don't see it
as a cat anymore yeah
that's true but still that the fact that
you say cat at the beginning
is that's already i don't think cnns
currently are even there
that you say cat and another interesting
point that i s
so what jan said is if i look at the
smartphone i see
the camera and the speakers and the
screen and i see the
usb port and whatnot but i would argue
i often don't see that if i look at a
smartphone
and i think it's a smartphone i'm like
it's almost i don't
see that there's a camera it's like
when you when you're when you're not
looking for the trash on the floor it
just doesn't exist
and uh so that's all i don't know what
to make of it but that's something that
i just noticed in myself i don't
always just like the objects seem to
appear
to you at the resolution where you are
interested in and yes i see you
you can they are for this compositional
nature but
it's not like all of this appears to you
when you look at them that's something i
find quite interesting
the actual resolution of the human eye
is actually really limited and we are
constantly
looking around and our brain is
stitching that image together
so maybe it that could be the reason why
and i was also more talking about
re-recognizing objects
we are not quite familiar off
i can recognize for example it was
a a transmission even i haven't really
seen it because i can recognize all the
components
all the gear screws exits into into
transmission belts but isn't that some
kind of topological
understanding that you have you
understand the system
or how things are connected to each
other and you can then reason
over that knowledge so it's not really a
pattern matching thing anymore
you load it into your framework of
understanding and you reason over it
again a really good point
i'm on i'm more on the side of it would
be a good idea to build this
sort of into our model this sort of
compositionality of objects
i don't think i think in the case of the
transmission example
that is maybe a case where you actually
need to load that into your reasoning
but in a lot of cases
you don't do you recognize a new car by
its four wheels right
and things like this it's not that you
explicitly
that the other extreme would be a
mathematician because they find
that they find the natural numbers
everywhere because they tested piano
axioms that that's the explicitly
ha i did not think that the natural
numbers would appear
in i don't know how circles are related
to each other but
there i go i test the piano axioms and
then
they are appear but i think that the
visual system does a lot of this
hierarchical
stuff by itself so i'm in the camp of
maybe it
should be a good idea to build this into
our models
just a quick point on that one the main
inductive prior that because we think of
feed forward neural networks as being a
blank slate but they do still have some
prizes and assumptions and
a hierarchical composition of concepts
is one of those
prizes yeah now we get it at a point
because it's a light different
from what i said to what john was saying
wanting basically
multi multiple labels per pixels and i'm
now talking about
priors and so on so i think yeah not
exactly representing what
what you said yeah i was more talking
about
the data and label and
label space unless about the model
itself
i don't think anyone would disagree with
you
the question is because it would be very
difficult it would be very onerous to
come up with a large data set which is
labeled in the way you're proposing oh
for sure
and my proposal for this would be
i would use language more specifically i
would use the movies and youtube
and as information objective information
in in this language in this videos and
in this movies is
lower than if we would exhaustively
describe all the pixels itself but
it would be actually a feasible way so
what i would
propose is that we would train a gpt
the style model that not only completes
language but
also predicts the next frame of the
video of a movie
and for example if someone in the
movie or video says i am now picking up
this text and now i am and now i'm
shopping this wood i don't know
we would have the information about what
x is
and what is and another benefit
we would then also let the model learn
some
let's call it reasoning over with this
objects
but also would be good and i am not
looking at it
from uh from a natural language
processing or understanding perspective
i am more looking at it from a computer
vision perspective where i would
use language to solve computer vision
one comment is you talked about
potentially having a billion labels
presumably that would underfit so you
would
do some hierarchical decomposition of
the words not just stemming but also a
volkswagen and a bmw you would change
that to car
because you need to presumably reduce
the number of tokens otherwise
you you wouldn't get good generalization
another question for yannick maybe is
i'm sure they're thinking about making a
gpt4
video and the current gpt model already
has
an input size of around 4.96 i think you
told me the other day jan
presumably that's enough to that's loads
of pixels right could they not just do a
vision version
you can there are transformers for
images and
presumably there can it's conceivable
to think of a transformer for video i
know that there are
efforts for doing exactly like doing
pre-training
vision mode like self-supervised on
video where
you're just trying to predict the next
frame they
i don't think they include language
quite yet but
this is a valid route i think and yeah
there's such a richness
in in video that is not explored by now
just think of humans watching a youtube
video about
something very often it's so much more
information than
looking at successive individual
pictures or
i'd rather watch a youtube video than
read a blog post or something like this
and yeah in a youtube video you often
get shown the actual thing right in a
blog post you maybe get it described and
that's where maybe wallet saba comes in
and says see there's
missing information because you can only
describe
things so i'm like the idea of
using video and the associated language
seems very promising because that's such
a data rich
such a data rich source
it's incredible the only caveat would be
because there are a lot of frames on
video it might be 25 frames a second
you would probably want to discretize
and associate the language with
a block of frames yeah there's
engineering challenges dissolved and as
well as there is
you know peop like you'd have to have
big buffers and so on because
if you decompose a video then all of a
sudden you have the problem of
correlated data points
because all of these data points that
you extract from one video they're
probably
heavily correlated and then if you want
to build a transformer you have
that giant problem right like how are
you going to do that
but maybe one of the recent linear
or quasi-linear attention things will
will solve that i don't know but it's i
i
like i'm on this seems like a very solid
idea
um yeah i'd be interested to know why i
don't know whether it's to do with the
representational capacity or
transformers are quite homogeneous
something whereas
these convolutional neural networks they
learn lots of bits of patterns that are
disjoint
different filters and so on i don't know
if i'm talking out of my backside there
but
transformers seem quite homogeneous and
maybe it's
i'm not sure and this is not an informed
thought this is just a
thought but this the cnns
we ever ever since
since young lacan and even further back
we've built them in a particular way
and so we've built them in a way that so
we have like
big receptive fields at the beginning
and then
you have small filters for a small
number of filters because
beyond the cons computer wasn't that big
and then
you reduce that and so on and and and
you go to higher number of filters
through the layers and transformers
don't do this they just keep
the same number of parameters in the
same number of tokens and so on through
all the layers i was wondering if you
built cnns this way what would happen if
you like really give it a try
but part of the explanation for that is
transformers are more of a blank slate
so cnn's the the specificity or the
inductive prior
is much more defined
so that there are more things to tweak
in that sense
there are more things to tweak on the
transformer we just don't do it
but we don't need to because on the
transformer
on the cnn we are very precisely
specifying
lots of small operations that happen in
a just disjoint way
whereas the transformer i visualize it
in my mind like there's this huge
pipe of information and we're not really
constraining or specifying how that
flows but still we could build cnns
in a way that is much less influenced by
what we think how we think information
should flow we could build them in a
all the layers have as many equally many
filters and
we don't do pooling and so on like
feasible i would argue that we have
spent quite a lot of time trying
different cnn architectures especially
hr net and some of the approaches to
rather than having a funnel maintain the
high resolution through the whole
network
we've done architecture research we've
done loads of different things and
what interests me is that actually it
kind of doesn't matter what you do
just because of the fidelity and
flexibility of neural networks
as long as you have a certain level of
capacity in your network it'll work well
but still transformers appear to be
better than cnns especially at something
like language right
yeah but is that something specific to
the substrate of language
who knows yeah this whole you know this
we were saying earlier language is
one-dimensional it's atomic it doesn't
actually have that many symmetries
yeah no i agree on that point i was just
it was just a weird
a weird thought and you're right we have
tried a lot of things with
cnns but maybe no one's
giving it the real good old google try
that makes things work the elon musk
approach
i think yeah that's exactly and that's a
bit my worry with the plan this plan of
building this
video transformer this is going to be
one scale up even with all the tricks
and so on this is going to be like
on a big scale like your data set are
going to be
big right and so on and the the problem
is with these kinds of models there are
effects
that only appear at a certain level
like they only start to manifest once
you reach a certain scale
and and the worry is a bit of can can
you get
to that scale with even let's say you
get a month of tensorflow research cloud
the the question is how far can you get
with that
not really far you fascinated me what
you just said there yeti so there are
effects which will manifest
at a scale well above where we're
working now
that really interests me because it also
what interests me is some people think
that with um
gpt3 eventually there'll be an emergent
phenomenon
there'll be some kind of emergent
phenomenon that will create something
completely different to what we've seen
before
but if you were a google what would you
do
because it's just so costly to work at
the scale how would they detect it how
would they
deal with it i i guess they would
they would also have to apply internally
if they were doing something like
ultra ultra big but at least it would be
let's say in the realm of possibilities
to go there yeah because it's similar to
the this massive sun
hadron collided what is it the big ring
thing in switzerland they're having to
build a bigger one
and then presumably they'll need to
build a bigger one and now it's just
become a multi-billion dollar project
and they can't really go one up anymore
yeah
yeah we do we do weird things in
switzerland
sorry this stuff
bye yeah see ya bye and we're done
so mr kilcher
wait we're still recording now i'm
joking
okay basically we we recorded this once
and then we realized at the end that we
weren't recording
and which has only happened to us once
when when we were with uh lena voiter
yeah we we chopped about 20 minutes off
the start of that
so yeah well saved culture anyway it's
been it's been a good year
i think you know we've got some
interesting things coming up next year
so
thank you all so much for subscribing
and for supporting us
and yeah have a fantastic new year and
we'll see you next week
bye bye cheers